Nein, nein. Die Klänge sind bekannt, mit Blick auf den Kalender sieht man 31. Oktober 2007, letzter Mittwoch im Monat, das heißt wieder Zeit für das Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Ihr seid herzlichst eingeladen zuzuhören, anzurufen und mitzumachen. Zu Gast ist der Chaos Computer Club in Form von Constanze und von Frank. Schönen Abend.
Schönen Abend.
Und wir reden heute über ein Thema, achso ich bin Jakob Kranstachchen. Wir reden heute über eine Sache, ich freue mich eigentlich das ganze Jahr auf diese Sendung. Bei dieser Sendung Chaosradio 129 widmet sich dem jährlich zu vergebenden und mittlerweile vergebenden Big Brother Award 2007. Frank sitzt auch in der Jury von den Leuten, die auswählen, wer in diesem Jahr den Preis bekommen hat für den größten Daten-Asi, den größten Datensammler und den größten Schindluder-Treiber in diesem Jahr. Es gibt verschiedene Kategorien, da werden wir nachher noch darauf eingehen. Und mit euch natürlich auch gerne darüber diskutieren, wer eurer Meinung nach einen Preis dafür verdient hat, mit euren persönlichen Daten umzugehen, wie der Bauer mit der Gießkanne auf dem Erdbeer beherrscht. Die Telefonnummer ist 0331 70 97 110 oder ihr klickt euch online rein auf fritz.de, da gibt es das Board, wo man auch mitmachen kann, oder aber auf chaosradio.ttc.de, da kann man sich in den Stream und sonstige Geschichten mit einklinken. Wartet richtig für einen Anfang. Wunderbar. Bevor wir aber über den Big Brother Awards 2007 reden, müssen wir noch über zwei andere Sachen reden, die natürlich extrem wichtig sind. Zum einen die Geschichte mit den Wahlstiften in Hamburg. Da kann Constanze eine Menge Sachen dazu erzählen. Das ist auch eine schöne Schweinerei.
Ja, wir wollen es deshalb mal heute erwähnen, weil da aktuell sich ein paar Sachen ergeben haben. Also wer es nicht mitbekommen hat, die Stadt Hamburg hat sich da so ein Projekt ausgedacht. Und zwar möchte es den Wählern für die Wahl im Februar so einen digitalen Wahlstift auswendigen, mit dem die Wähler in Hamburg dann ihr Kreuz zwar immer noch auf dem Papier machen, aber dennoch wird mit diesem digitalen Wahlstift das Ergebnis computerisiert gezählt. Na ja, und kürzlich haben wir da den Hamburger Politikern da so einen Hack vorgeführt. Das heißt, wir haben ganz grundsätzliche Bedenken gegen diesen Wahlstift. Und jetzt sind wir damit auch an der Öffentlichkeit gegangen. Und jetzt haben wir eigentlich ein gewisses Ziel erreicht. Und zwar einfach nur, dass wir am 9. November in Hamburg nochmal gehört werden und unsere Bedenken davor tragen dürfen.
Es gab ja schonmal Ärger um diese Wahlcomputerfirma. Die war mal hieß Neda, glaube ich. Die holländische Firma, das waren diese Wahlcomputer, die unter anderem in Cottbus versuchsweise eingesetzt wurden.
Ach, und viel mehr Stellen gibt es mittlerweile. Also einige tausend, also 1850 von diesen Wahlcomputern.
Ich dachte nur Cottbus, weil es ja quasi auch so ein bisschen Sende wird und Regeln. Wo auch mehr Sachen schiefgegangen sind, als sich alle Beteiligten gewünscht oder gehofft hatten. Und die Geschichte mit diesen Neda Maschinen ist jetzt ein bisschen vom Tisch. Verwunderlicherweise ist es, dass die Hamburger denken, oh, machen wir gleich die nächste elektronische Spiele rein, komm mit einem elektronischen Wahlstift. Wie funktioniert das Ding eigentlich?
Na, es ist eigentlich ein wirklich einfaches Gerät, was jetzt von der Benutzerführung denkbar einfach ist. Man bekommt also eine Art Kuli ausgehändigt, der ist ein bisschen dicker als ein Gugelschreiber, eher so wie so ein Besenstiel, so dick.
Aber man kann den ganz normal quasi wie einen Stift festhalten.
Ja genau, da hat eine normale Mine eben, sieht aus wie ein Kuli, nur ein bisschen dicker. Und dann kriegt man dazu das Wahlbuch in Hamburg, denn die haben nicht nur einen Wahlzettel, sondern ein Buch voller Zettel. Und auf diesem Papier, was man da auskennig bekommt, ist halt ein Muster. Und für normale Augen von Menschen ist es nicht sehr sichtbar. So kleine Mikrodots. Und anhand dieser Punkte auf diesem Papier kann der digitale Wahlstift erkennen, wo der wieder sein Kreuz macht. Sprich, in dem kleinen Stift ist halt eine Kamera, ist eine Sensorik, die diese Punkte erkennt.
Und wenn zwischendurch die Batterie alle ist, geht es nicht mehr.
Ja, aber also robust ist dieses Gerät und sie haben auch mehrere von diesen Wahlstiften im Wahllokal. Es geht nicht darum, dass wir glauben, das nicht funktioniert im Sinne von Robustheit, sondern es geht eher um die Sicherheit. Also wir haben auch hier sehr schwere Bedenken in Bezug auf die Manipulationsfreiheit und vor allen Dingen auch in Bezug auf die Nachvollziehbarkeit und Transparenz des Verfahrens. Denn erzählt wird den Hamburger, dass sie auf Zettel wählen. Aber eigentlich ist es wirklich eine Computerwahl, denn wenn der Wähler im Wahllokal seinen eigenen Füller aus der Tasche zieht und sein Kreuz mit diesem Füller macht, dann wird diese Stimme nicht gezählt, obwohl der Wählerwille ganz normal abgegeben wurde.
Wenn ich jetzt mit diesem digitalen Stift auf dieses Papier mit dem Mikro dort mein Kreuz mache, wie geht das dann weiter?
Na, ist eigentlich auch ein einfacher Prozess. Man gibt dem den Wahlhelfer den Stift zurück, wenn man aus der Wahlkabine rauskommt und dann wird er in so eine kleine Auslesestation, so ein Docking Station, gesteckt und über USB wird dann diese eine Stimme auf einem Laptop gespeichert und dann im Laufe des Tages eben, wenn die Stimme aufsummiert. Also der Prozess ist für den W da jetzt nicht groß anders als eine Papierwahl, nur eben, dass der Stift anders ist. Und für die Briefwahlstimmen haben sie sich dann da überlegt, dass sie tatsächlich die Leute, die per Brief wählen, da wollen sie mit diesem digitalen Wahlstift die Stimme nachmalen, um die auch zählen zu können. Das fanden wir natürlich auch einigermaßen lächerlich. Wir haben hier auch eine interessante Allianz mit den Juristen, denn es gibt gleich mehrere sehr bekannte Verfassungsrechtler, die sofort gesagt haben, also das ist natürlich verfassungsrechtlich sehr bedenklich, weil sie einfach die Stimmen nicht zählen, die mit normalen Kugelschreiber abgegeben sind und das natürlich irgendwie bedenklich.
Wo ist denn jetzt das eigentliche Sicherheitsloch noch mal ganz genau? Also der Stift wird abgegeben, das wird über ein Lesegerät in den Rechner eingespielt und dann gibt es noch ein Programm, was die Stimmen zählt.
Ja, also da haben wir sehr, sehr verschiedene Ebenen an Sicherheitslöchern entdeckt. Also was wir jetzt momentan erst mal vorgeführt haben, den sogenannten Trojanischen Wahlstift, hier wird einfach der Stift, also wir haben die Hardware verändert, so dass man mit dem Einstecken auf die Auslesestation und man den Stift quasi zurückgibt, dass man dann über die über die USB-Schnittstelle versucht, den Computer, der zusammen zählt, zu manipulieren an die Software auf diesem Computer. Da gibt es natürlich sehr verschiedene Wege. Man versucht also einen Exploit auszunutzen, aber man kann natürlich auch an das Papier denken, dass man also versucht, übers Papier zu hacken, denn der Wähler kann natürlich diese kleinen Mikrodots dort nicht selbst identifizieren, der weiß nicht, was wirklich gezählt wird. Also er kann sich nur darauf verlassen, dass eben Hamburg sagt, dieser Stift ist sicher und da haben wir unsere berechtigten Zweifel.
Nachdem es schon Zweifel gab an dem Einsatz dieser NEDAP-Wahlmaschinen, ist natürlich auch die Skepsis gegenüber der Computerwahl sehr weit verbreitet und größer geworden. Mit welchem Argument kommt denn jetzt Hamburg um die Ecke und sagt, wir machen es jetzt doch noch mal auf diesem Weg, der eigentlich kritisiert wird?
Ihr eigentliches Argument ist dieses sehr komplizierte Wahlverfahren, oder Sie sagen, es sei kompliziert, es gibt auch andere Wahlverfahren, anderen Bundesländern, die recht kompliziert sind, weil man kann jetzt in Hamburg diese kumulieren und panaschieren, in diesem Wahlprozess machen. Also man kann Stimmen häufeln und man gibt natürlich viel mehr als eine Stimme ab. Und insofern haben Sie quasi durch dieses komplizierte Wahlverfahren gedacht, das computerisieren wir und so haben wir das Ergebnis wieder schneller und können eventuell diese ehrenamtlichen Wahlhelfer einsparen, also einige davon. Also es ist schon durchaus von vornherein ein Kostenargument.
Aber ein ehrenamtlicher Wahlhelfer, wenn er ehrenamtlich arbeitet, ist ja dieser Einsparungseffekt ja relativ gering.
Ja, argumentieren tun die Hamburger Stadtväter darüber, dass sie sagen, man kann das nicht mehr an dem Abend nachzielen. Das heißt, wir müssten mehrere Tage lang ehrenamtliche anstellen und das würde dann irgendwie doch Geld kosten. Also sie haben sich selbst diese komplizierte Wahlverfahren gegeben, um dann zu sagen, oh super, wir haben jetzt zwar, das ist alles sehr kompliziert, aber wir haben eine technische Lösung und also damit ist natürlich auch ein gewisser, einfach eine Vertrauensfrage, die da wieder aufkommt, denn sie können bisher nur hoffen, dass die Hamburger in dieses System vertrauen und wir werden als Chaos Computer Club da nicht müde uns mit der Hardware und dem ganzen System zu befassen, um zu zeigen, dass das eben nicht sicher ist.
Gibt es in anderen Regionen, Ländern, Städten schon die Idee, das ähnlich wie in Hamburg einzusetzen? Ist das eine Art Testballon?
Na sicher, verspricht sich die kommerziellen Anbieter hinter dem System schon, dass sie nachher dieses erfolgreiche Wahlstiftsystem exportieren können. Aber bisher ist Hamburg solitär. Andere gibt es da bisher nicht. Die kommerziellen Hersteller, genau wie bei NEDAP, hoffen sich, dass sie das weiter verkaufen können.
Also Wahl im nächsten Jahr, Anhörung von euch, ist am 9. November. Das ist in der kommenden Woche am Samstag, oder? Freitag, Samstag, irgendwie. Weil mal 7. ist Mittwoch, 8. und 9. Freitag. Also Freitag kommende Woche. Werdet ihr dann noch mal gehört, wie groß sind die Chancen, dass das Ganze noch kippt?
Na ja, in Hamburg gibt es natürlich mehrere Probleme. Wir hoffen, dass wir die Politiker schlicht mit Argumenten überzeugen können, denn wir haben sehr gute Argumente und wir werden sicherlich auch noch mal sehr konkrete Sicherheitsprobleme dort vorführen können. Und da das Gesetz, das Hamburger Wahlgesetz, noch nicht durch ist, sondern die Parteien eben darüber konkret noch entscheiden, hoffen wir schon, dass sie sich noch besinnen. Ich meine, sie haben halt die Gelder dort schon ausgegeben. Insofern haben sie ein Problem, ihren Weden zu erklären, warum die 5 Millionen da rausgegeben wurden. Aber wir hoffen da schon, dass die Vernunft siegt. Und auch vielleicht ein bisschen die vielen internationalen Beispiele, wo sich eben andere Entscheider in der Politik derart blamiert haben mit solchen Systemen.
Na mal gucken, wie viel Bleistifte man für 5 Millionen Euro kaufen könnte. Das ist die andere Seite. Wie gesagt, Ende nächster Woche gibt es da eine Anhörung. Wir bleiben weiter dran, informieren euch natürlich, was da bei diesem Hamburger Wahlstift, Dingens möchte ich es mal bezeichnen, weiter passiert und kommen dann so ein bisschen über so einen kleinen Schlenker noch nicht zur heutigen Sendung.
Eine Sache wäre noch, wer sich für die technischen Details interessiert, für den haben wir beim Chaosradio Express eine Sendung. Ich glaube, die war so etwa zwei Stunden, die haben wir gestern aufgezeichnet. Die kann man sich downloaden als Podcast. Also da haben wir mal ein bisschen die technischen Details erklärt, was wir eigentlich wirklich gemacht haben. Ist aber relativ lang und würde hier den Rahmen springen.
Aber da kann man sich dann in Ruhe hinsetzen und mitschreiben. Den Podcast gibt es bei ccc.de.
Genau. Da können wir uns bei der Gelegenheit auch nochmal bedanken. Die Hamburger, also gerade der Hamburger CCC hat sich da doch sehr ins Zeug gelegt, weil gerade in Hamburg auch die Leute betrifft. Da haben sie echt gute Arbeit gelässt.
So jetzt aber der Schlenker.
Genau.
Dein Mikrofon ist offen, Frank.
Nee, du hörst mich im Ohr, bin ich ganz leise?
Du sprichst.
Ich?
Ja, dann.
Du sprichst, wir hören dich, alles ist schön.
Wunderbar. Wir wollen heute über die Big Brother Awards sprechen und wollen die vorstellen. Der Big Brother Award ist ein Negativ-Datenschutz-Preis und geht an die größten Datenkraken. Das funktioniert so, dass Mitte des Jahres wieder zur Nominierung aufgerufen wird. Das heißt also, die Leute, die Bevölkerung, also ihr, schickt der Jury Vorschläge. Es gab dieses Jahr ungefähr 500 Vorschläge. Dann gibt es eine Jury, die ganz bunt zusammengemischt ist. Das sind, sag ich mal, Leute, die veröffentlichen, also Publizisten, es sind Juristen, es sind aber auch Techniker, Informatiker. Du bist mit drin? Ich bin da mit drin als Chaos Computer Club. Das heißt, wir haben dann mehr so ein bisschen die technischen Sachen. Aber wir betrachten die Sachen jetzt nicht nur von der technischen Seite, sondern wir wollen vor allem auch Preise an die, sag ich mal, Firmen, Institutionen, Politiker vergeben, die jetzt ganz besonders hervorhebenswert sind. Das heißt, wir wollen den Preis gar nicht an irgendwelche Firmen oder Politiker vergeben, die jetzt wieso immer schon im Rampenlicht stehen mit ihren Ideen. Deswegen hat auch der Herr Schäuble dieses Jahr keinen Preis bekommen. Kann ich ja gleich mal vorwegnehmen.
Der hat auch eigentlich schon genug, oder?
Ja, der ist sowieso immer irgendwie überall. Und deswegen haben wir uns entschieden, der kriegt ihn jetzt nicht. Wir wollen ein bisschen die Sachen ins Licht holen, die eigentlich sonst untergehen, worüber keiner spricht oder wo vielleicht mal eine kleine Meldung irgendwie in Zeitungen am Rande ist, die aber vielleicht auch nicht über die üblichen Netzweltgeschichten hinausgeht. Und die wollen wir einfach ein bisschen hervorheben, und dass darüber noch mal gesprochen wird oder Sachen, die jetzt auch schon länger herliegen, also zurückliegen im Jahr und wo es dann einfach noch mal lohnt, die noch mal hochzuholen, sagen, das war eigentlich eine ganz schöne Sauerei. Und es geht dabei eben auch nicht zu betrachten, ob das jetzt wirklich, sagen wir mal, rein formal juristisch irgendwie vielleicht gerade noch so zulässig ist, ob sie da irgendwie ein Schlupfloch gefunden haben oder irgendwie eine komische Regelung, sondern wir sagen, selbst wenn es jetzt irgendwie vor Gericht bestand hätte, wir finden es trotzdem eine Sauerei und deswegen gibt es einen Preis dafür.
Man sollte vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz, um den Big Brother Award zu erklären, ganz kurz in der Geschichte rühren. Big Brother Award gibt es jetzt seit neun Jahren.
Seit sieben Jahren in Deutschland. Seit sieben Jahren in Deutschland und wird ausgerichtet vom FÖBUD, das ist ein Kurzname für den Verein zur Förderung des bewegenden und unbewegenden Datenverkehrs. Das ist ein Bielefeld und ist ein Verein, der im Prinzip aus der Mailbox-Szene hervorgegangen ist, also die sich auch schon ganz früh, als die Leute die ersten Computer zu Hause hatten, dafür eingesetzt haben, dass es freie Kommunikation gab, öffentliche Kommunikationsnetze per Computer. Also damals hat man sich noch per Akustikkoppler, per Modem eingewählt. Und es waren eigentlich so die Vorläufer der heutigen Webseiten und E-Mail-Systeme, Verteilerlisten. Und die sind in Bielefeld. Das ist ein sehr engagiertes Team, vor allem Padelun und Rena. Aber mittlerweile ist ein riesiges Team, was daran hängt. 30 Leute und mehr, die diese ganze Veranstaltung, die Preisverleihung vorbereiten, die die Unterlagen für die Jury aufbereiten. Das ist also so, die sammeln die Vorschläge und dann kommt ja nicht konspirativ, aber schon unter doch recht hoher Geheimhaltung trifft sich dann die Jury entsprechend vorher. Dann werden die ganzen Sachen gesichtet. Wir sitzen da einen ganzen Tag drüber beraten. Es ist mittlerweile nach sieben Jahren auch so ein bisschen nicht Routine. Es sind halt immer schon Sachen dabei, die uns wirklich auch noch schocken. Es sind viele Sachen dabei, wo wir denken, ah, schon wieder eine Kundenkarte und so. Aber wir finden jedes Mal immer wieder was, was dann doch preiswürdig ist. Und dann geht es los. Dann ziehen wir uns alle zurück. Unsere Kämmerlein mehr oder weniger schreiben, unsere Laudatio. Das heißt also eine Begründungstext, warum das jetzt der Preisträger bekommt, den Preis, die Auszeichnung. Es gibt eine Recherche. Wir schauen nochmal, was da sonst passiert ist, ob wir noch mehr Informationen rauskriegen als das, was uns bei den Nominierungen angetragen worden ist. Und dann gibt es die große Preisverleihung in Bielefeld. Und da werden die Preise dann der Öffentlichkeit vorgestellt, die Preisträger, die werden auch alle eingeladen, über die Presseabteilung, über die Geschäftsführer. Bisher, muss man aber sagen, es war wirklich bisher nur ein Preisträger, nämlich die Firma Microsoft, die genug Arsch in der Hose hatte, um wirklich zu kommen, diesen Preis abzuholen. Und sie haben das auch wirklich professionell gemacht, muss ich auch mal dazu sagen.
Die haben den Preis gekriegt für ihr Digital Rights Management System.
Die haben einen lebenslangen Preis oder einen Lifetime Award bekommen. Sie können es einfach nicht lassen. Ich muss aber auch sagen, dass tatsächlich mittlerweile auch ein bisschen Umdenken bei Microsoft stattgefunden hat. Und sie haben auch Datenschutz und Privatsphäre auch als Marktwert erkannt. Das hat auch ein bisschen gefruchtet. Und es war einfach gut, dass sie da waren. Und es war ein professioneller Auftritt und wir haben uns darüber gefreut. Und ich denke, für die war das auch mal ganz okay. Und seitdem hat es aber leider keinen Preisträger, hat sich mehr getraut, zu kommen.
Das ist halt schade, denn man muss sich überlegen, wofür dieser Big Brother Award ist. Es geht halt wirklich darum, da einen Gespräch in Gang zu bringen. Also es geht gar nicht um diese Du-Du, ihr seid alle irgendwie fies und böse, sondern man möchte eigentlich mit denen anfangen zu reden, damit sie eben was ändern. Und vielleicht auch damit zu erkennen, dass irgendwie Datenschutz und Privatheit und eine andere Behandlung von Daten gut ankommt bei den Konsumenten.
Damit fangen wir heute schon mal an. Wir haben ja knapp zwei Stunden Zeit, um über die Big Brother Awards 2007 zu reden. Wir werden euch einige der Preisträger vorstellen. Da sind unter anderem nur Spezialisten dabei, wie die Deutsche Bahn oder mehrere große Hotelketten und so. Warum, das klären wir alles nachher noch. Wir können auch gerne noch mal auf die Best-of der letzten Jahre eingehen. Da gibt es auch so ein paar, die ich mir gerne auch an die Wand hängen würde, weil ich denke, wie kommt man eigentlich auf so eine hirnrissige Idee. Das können wir alles nachher machen. Und wie gesagt, ihr könnt gerne mitdiskutieren, anrufen 0331 70 97 110 oder aber euch unter den bekannten Adressen ins Netz klinken und dann mitdiskutieren. Also entweder unter chaosradio.ccc.de oder aber unter fritz.de. Wollen wir gleich einsteigen oder wollen wir erstmal eine Musik spielen?
Ja, wenn es schon Vorschläge gibt, also die Idee ist ja, dass ihr anruft und eure Vorschläge, wer sind eure Kandidaten für den Big Brother Award? Wem würdet ihr diesen Preis geben?
Ja, wir fragen mal. Wir haben einen Anruf aus Wuppertal von Cyberpunk.
Guten Abend.
Ja, ich rufe heute das erste Mal an. Heißt nicht, dass ich jetzt das erste Mal Chaosradio höre. Herzlich willkommen. Ich habe eine Menge Wendungen verfolgt und habe mir inzwischen einiges Müll für euch gemacht.
Okay, also Big Brother Awards 2007 ist heute das Thema. Wer ist denn deiner Meinung nach jemand, der auf jeden Fall eine Auszeichnung kriegen sollte in diesem Jahr?
Es gibt eine Firma, das Problem ist, ich weiß nicht ganz genau den Namen dazu. Ich hab den irgendwie im Kopf, aber komm jetzt nicht genau drauf. Es geht ums Telefonscoring und zwar ist, ich sag mal, man ruft bei einer Hotline an und kriegt automatisch halt eben so ein Score zugewiesen. Nach dem Motto, das war ein freundlicher Kunde, das war irgendwie ein unfreundlicher Kunde, war einer, weiß nicht, der nervig war oder wie auch immer, kriegt halt eben irgendwie, ich sag mal jetzt, über eine Zahl von eins bis zehn einen Score zugewiesen. Und beim nächsten Mal wird der halt eben nicht ernst genommen oder, sag ich mal, kriegt jetzt einen ganz schlechten Bettmark. Und, sag ich mal, es rufen, sagen wir mal, 50 Leute an. Der hat einen Score von zehn, das heißt ganz schlecht. Und dann wird der immer weiter nach hinten gestellt.
Und der ist in einer Warteschleife dann, ja.
Und dann wird er so langsam nach vorne geschoben. So kann es sein, dass man, sag ich mal, jetzt drei Stunden in einer Warteschleife hängt und überhaupt gar nicht rankommt.
Ich muss jetzt mal ganz dumm fragen. Glaubst du, das ist nur eine Firma, die das so macht?
Ne, das ist ja so ein Verband selber. Es gibt ja sicherlich eine Firma, die das, sag ich mal wie Payback oder sonst was, Payback ist ja schon lange nominiert, darf man ja nicht mehr nominieren, die das halt eben mit reinsetzt.
Also diese Callcenter-Geschichten sind natürlich auf jeden Fall problematisch, das muss man mal sagen, weil zum einen fallen da ziemlich viele Daten an. Es ist so, dass Callcenter in der Regel ja nur, nicht nur für eine Firma arbeiten, sondern die haben einen Branchenmix. Also das ist auch nicht so, dass sie für Konkurrenten arbeiten, Wettbewerber arbeiten, in einer Branche, sondern es ist so, die haben ein ziemlich breites Portfolio. Das heißt, sie haben eine Versicherung, eine Bank, einen Telefonbetreiber und vielleicht eine Krankenkasse oder sowas.
Oh, jemand vom Fach.
Ich sag mal für den Vertrieb von Versatel. Das war jetzt eine legitime Sache. Anständig ein Produkt vorstellen und sonst was. Das war anständig, aber es gibt auch Sachen wie SKL oder sonst was. Einfach ein Pseudoprodukt vorstellen, ohne irgendeinen Nutzen.
Ich muss gleich mal nachfragen, bei Versatel, das war ja sozusagen Outbound, das heißt, ich hab Leute angerufen wahrscheinlich. Kriegt man da nicht auch einen Flag, wenn man besonders unfreundlich ist zu denen am Telefon, dass sie nicht wieder anrufen? Kriegt man einen was? Dass man auch so eine Bewertung kriegt, wenn man besonders unfreundlich war zu denen am Telefon.
Nee, dabei wurde das halt eben nicht mitgemacht.
Deswegen rufen die immer an bei mir.
Du hattest die Telefonnummern, die du dann anrufen solltest, die hatten nicht einen Scorewert, ne?
Im Nachhinein hab ich jetzt mitgekriegt, dass es, ich sag mal, ich bewähre es jetzt nicht als so alt, so negativ, aber es ist ja im Prinzip unlautere Wettbewerb, muss man ja auch sagen.
Okay, das ist natürlich noch eine andere Problematik, außer der Datenschutzproblematik. Sind eigentlich ernsthaft schon mal...
Aber man kriegt im Prinzip, wenn ich mal kurz sagen darf, man kriegt, sag ich mal, so ein Stapel in die Hand gedrückt. Insgesamt hat man so einen 4000er Stapel. Das heißt, da steht halt, ich weiß nicht... Moment, was?
Ein Stapel mit 4000 Nummern?
4000 Nummern und dann wird das halt eben ausgegeben. Jeder kriegt, sag ich mal, pro Stunde, sag ich mal, 20er Bearbeitert. Und die arbeitet er ab. Dann holt er sich halt eben neues ab. Und da steht halt, ich sag mal, der Kunde, die Adresse, die Telefonnummer und so. Und den Rest arbeitet man halt eben an so einem Bogen halt eben ab. Sprich, so da halt, sag ich mal, so ein paar Informationen mitzukriegen. Und neidermäßig ergeben sich natürlich auch teilweise so ein paar Sachen nach dem Motto, der ist jetzt verstorben oder sonst was.
Hm, die schreibt man dann dazu.
Oder ist doppelt, dreifach, zehnfach kontaktiert, also überkontaktiert, dann sind natürlich auch wieder schlechter.
War da eigentlich auch irgendwelche Mobilnummern bei oder war alles Festnetz?
Bin ich jetzt gerade am Überlegen. Also Festnetz auf jeden Fall Mobilnummern glaube ich in den wenigsten Fällen.
Aber lass uns nochmal, ich würde gerne zum Anfang der Intention des Anrufs zurückkommen, aber zwar zu dem Scoring in Telefon-Hotlines. Du hast ja gerade so ein bisschen erzählt, wie es bei Telefon-Hotlines so läuft und so.
Das ist jetzt nicht spezifisch eine Hotline, sondern es gibt darunter ein Netzwerk, dass sich alle Hotlines so und so absprechen können und sag ich mal einen allgemeinen Score dafür gibt. Wer hat jetzt bei Staubsaugerunternehmen angerufen und da hat er schon einen schlechten Score, das kommt aber jetzt nicht. Dann kriegt nicht aufgelistet, dass er jetzt bei diesen Staubsaugerunternehmen angerufen hat.
Aber du weißt schon, da kommt ein Problem vor.
Sondern kriegt einfach einen Score vorgelegt und seht daran irgendwie eine negative oder positive Bewertung.
Okay, Frage an alle Beteiligten und auch euch, wenn ihr zuhört. Würde mich sehr interessieren, wenn man sich irgendwie an irgendeiner Hotline, du warst genervt, warst laut, hast gesagt, ihr könnt mich mal irgendwas. Und wenn du jetzt gerade sagst, man kriegt da irgendwie einen schlechten Score, kann man sich dann später irgendwie rehabilitieren? Kann man sagen, oh tut mir leid, möchte ich nicht? Man kann das alles wieder auf Null schieben lassen und wieder von vorne anfangen? Oder ist es irgendwie einmal Assi gewesen, immer Assi?
Also zumindestens kann man sich da, hat man das Recht darauf, dass wir erfahren, was wir gespeichert haben überein. Und kann dann eine Auskunft verlangen, was wir alles gespeichert haben überein. Theoretisch, ja.
Wurde denn eigentlich von der Big Brother Awards Jury schon jemals Call Center als Preisträger nominiert worden?
Nicht so direkt. Weil es natürlich ein bisschen schwierig war, die machen ja sogenannte Datenverarbeitung im Auftrag. Das heißt, die sammeln die Daten ja selbst nicht in der Regel. Das heißt, es sind beauftragte Dienstleister, die sitzen da und telefonieren. Wenn jetzt anfangen würden, selbst Daten zusammenzuführen, quasi erzählen plötzlich, ach, ich sehe ja gerade in dem anderen System, sie haben ja auch noch ein Bankkonto, haben sie da nicht Interesse, ihre Bank zu wechseln, dann würde es natürlich kritisch werden, wenn so was bekannt wird und so was systematisch gemacht wird. Aber in der Regel achten die natürlich schon auf so was und sind da üblicherweise auch recht sauber, was was angeht.
Core Center ist, glaube ich, schon mal eine Spitzenidee für einen Anfang von der Diskussion. Ich freue mich sehr auf die preistregende Kombination nachher, Frank. Wir reden über die Big Brother Awards 2007 im heutigen Chaos Radio Teil 129. Und ihr könnt gerne mitdiskutieren und eure Vorschläge machen über die Datensammler und Datenschindludertreiber in diesem Jahr, was euch da so einfällt, können wir gerne drüber reden, unter der 0331 70 97 110. Vielen Dank nach Wuppertal.
Ich wollte mal was melden und das war... Okay, super. Ihr hattet das ja früher drei Stunden, jetzt ist es auf zwei Stunden gekürzt. Vorher war das, sag ich mal, drei Stunden, da hat man immer so ein bisschen, ja ich sag mir jetzt nicht labern, aber ich hab mal so ein bisschen gemütlich diskutieren können. Und ich hab jetzt gemerkt, dass das so auf zwei Stunden runtergekürzt wurde.
Dass man nicht mehr gemütlich diskutieren kann.
Das ist jetzt teilweise so, hab ich jetzt gerade bei diesen Anrufen nicht mitbekommen, aber bei anderen irgendwie, dass es so teilweise so ein bisschen abgehakt wird. So nach dem Motto, ja jetzt zieh mal Cat-Uhr und so. Ich fand's eigentlich recht schön, wenn auch mal irgendwie so, sei mal ein paar Sachen irgendwie spezifischer diskutiert wurden, also ein bisschen tiefer ins Detail und so.
Naja, das ist natürlich für uns ein bisschen schwierig mit der gekürzten Zeit und das kommt noch mehr dazu, außer nur, dass die Stunde jetzt fehlt. Wir haben nämlich deutlich mehr Anrufer. Und da ist es manchmal sehr schwierig für uns hier im Studio, dass wir sagen, okay, da sind so viele in der Leitung, wir müssen manchmal einfach was kürzen, wir haben da gar keine andere Wahl, einfach weil so viele warten in der Hotline da und die wollen wir ja nun auch nicht irgendwie einen Minuten lang hängen lassen oder manchmal eine Stunde. Ist natürlich immer ein bisschen schwierig, aber es ist für uns immer eine Gratwanderung.
Ich sag's mal so rum, lieber zwei Stunden Chaosradio machen, als gar kein Chaosradio machen. Und deswegen machen wir gleich die Nachrichten und deswegen schmeiß ich dich jetzt auch raus, weil jetzt haben wir keine Zeit mehr. Übrigens heute ist ja Halloween, deswegen noch ein bisschen Crams, ich war ein Teenage Werewolf.
Ich bin ein Künstler, ich bin ein Künstler.
Ich bin ein Künstler, ich bin ein Künstler. Hallo, wer ist denn da? Fritz würde gern mal bei euch klingeln. Wenn ihr wollt, dass wir zu euch kommen, werdet Fritz Freunde. Dann besucht euch Fritz mit ganz viel neuer Musik. Wir holen nämlich eure Meinung dazu. Zuerst neue Musik anhören, dann sagen, was ihr davon haltet. Und als kleines Dankeschön gibt's was auf die Ohren.
Ein speziell für MP3 geeigneter Kopfhörer CX-52 von Sennheiser? Für mich?
Tja, kleines Gastgeschenk.
Werdet Fritz Freunde.
Ladet uns jetzt ein. Alle Infos zum Fritz Freunde werden fritz.de. Neue Musik spielen wir zuerst bei euch.
Und das hört man kurz nach halb elf. Mit Philipp Burger.
Der Tropensturm Noel hat Kurs auf die Bahamas genommen, zuvor war er über Kuba hinweggezogen. Nach Angaben der kubanischen Regierung wurden durch heftige Regenfälle etwa 1000 Wohnhäuser beschädigt. 2000 Menschen mussten in Sicherheit gebracht werden. Der Tropensturm hat in der Dominikanischen Republik und in Haiti bisher über 80 Menschen getötet und große Schäden angerichtet. In beiden Ländern werden noch viele Bewohner vermisst. Im Terrorprozess von Madrid wurden 21 von insgesamt 28 Angeklagte zu langjährigen Haftstrafen verurteilt. Drei der Hauptangeklagten, zwei Marokkaner und ein Spanier, müssen für jeweils 40 Jahre ins Gefängnis, so die Entscheidung des Nationalen Gerichtshofs. Bei den Anschlägen auf vier Züge waren im März 2004 191 Menschen getötet worden. Opfern und Unterhinterbliebenen wurden Entschädigungsgeld dazu gesprochen. Die Bundesregierung will deutsche Unternehmen und Industrien vor ausländischen Übernahmen schützen. Das Wirtschaftsministerium will deshalb ausländische Beteiligungen von mehr als 25 Prozent genehmigungspflichtig machen. Entsprechend soll das Außenwirtschaftsgesetz geändert werden. Die Bundesregierung will verhindern, dass sich milliardenschwere Fonds aus Russland, China oder den Golfstaaten in deutsche Firmen einkaufen. Zur Erinnerung an die Berliner Mauer ist am Randenburger Tor eine neue Lichtanlage installiert worden. Bis zum 9. November, dem Tag des Mauerfalls, wird ein Teil der Mauer mit leuchtenden Wänden nachgestellt. Das Lichtkunstwerk ist 23 Meter lang und wird, wie die originale Mauer, drei Meter hoch sein. Eine Künstlerin aus Südkorea hat sich die Lichtshow ausgedacht. Sie möchte damit an die Deutsch-Deutsche Geschichte und an die politische Situation des heute noch geteilten Koreas erinnern. VfB Stuttgart, Karls heißt Jena, Werder Bremen, der Hamburger SV, Borussia Dortmund und Rot-Weiß Essen haben das Achtelfinale des DFB Pokals erreicht. Bremen besiegte Oesburg 4 zu 0, Hamburg gewann gegen Freiburg 3 zu 1, Dortmund schlug Frankfurt 2 zu 1, Essen schickt Kaiserslautern mit 2 zu 1 aus dem Rennen, Jena besiegt den amtierenden Pokalgewinner Nürnberg 4 zu 5 nach 11 Meter Schießen. Die Partie Bayern München gegen Mönchengladbach läuft noch, es steht 3 zu 1 für die Bayern. In der Basketball-Bundesliga hat Alba Berlin das Heimspiel gegen Trier gewonnen, Berlin siegte mit 92 zu 81 und steht damit auf dem dritten Tabellenplatz. Ebenfalls einen Sieg gab es für die Eisbären, die Berliner gewannen in der deutschen Ice Hockey-Liga gegen Nürnberg mit 5 zu 2. Heute Nacht ist der Himmel wolkig oder zumindest locker bewölkt, es bleibt aber trocken bei Tiefstwerten zwischen 7 bis 2 Grad in den frühen Morgenstunden. Von der Priegnitz bis zur Uckermark bestimmt eine dicke Wolkendecke auch morgen das Wetter örtlich kann es Sprühregen geben. Im Süden und in Berlin sieht der Himmel aber morgen ein bisschen besser aus. Am meisten Sonne gibt es in Richtung Neiße. 9 bis 13 Grad werden es morgen. Die aktuellen Temperaturen. Cottbus 6 Grad, Potsdam 8 Grad, Frankfurt 8 Grad, Neuropin 9 Grad, Wittenberge 9 Grad, Angermünde 10 Grad, Berlin 9 Grad. A24 Richtung Berliner Ringen zwischen Herzsprung und Neuropin, Gefahr durch ein defektes Fahrzeug, ein Pkw steht unbeleuchtet auf dem Standstreifen. Stadtverkehr Berlin A100, Stadtring Richtung Wedding, zwischen Dreieckfunkturm und Kaiserdamm ist der linke Fahrstreifen gesperrt. Der Stadtring Richtung Neukölln zwischen dem Kreuz Schöneberg und der Ausfahrt Oberlandstraße ist der rechte Fahrstreifen gesperrt und A111 statt einwärts im Tunnel Ortskern Tegel ist heute Nacht der rechte Fahrstreifen gesperrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Heute ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat, das heißt heute wie immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat Chaosradio. Heute Teil 129 auf Fritz mit Konstanze, mit Frank. Mein Name ist Jakob, guten Abend. Und wir reden über die Big Brother Awards 2007.
Wir haben es ja gerade schon mal so ein bisschen angedeutet, was die Big Brother Awards sind, dass sie gerade verteilt wurden und kommen jetzt zu den einzelnen, wenn sie Nominis sind. Genau, damit wir uns das mal richtig vorstellen können, wie so eine Preisverleihung abläuft, haben wir da jetzt auch mal einen kleinen Mitschnitt, einen kleinen Audioschnitzel mitgebracht. Vielleicht sagen sie es hat von Damen Mikrofon aufgenommen, ist leider nicht so toll von der Qualität, aber das kriegt er schon hin. Und der Preis geht an Frau Zypries für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Frau Bundesministerin Zypries, Sie werden ausgezeichnet für Ihren Gesetzentwurf, mit dem in Deutschland die Vorratsdatenspeicherung von Telekommunikationsverbindungsdaten eingeführt werden sollen. Sie ignorieren damit bewusst die Rechtsprechung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts, das bereits 1983 im Volkszählungsurteil festgelegt hatte, dass die Sammlung von nicht anonymisierten Daten zu unbestimmten oder noch nicht bestimmbaren Zwecken mit dem Grundgesetz unvereinbar ist. Ausgangspunkt für Ihren Gesetzentwurf ist die Richtlinie mit der amtlichen Bezeichnung 2006-24-EG der Europäischen Union. Nach dieser Richtlinie müssen alle Mitgliedsstaaten, die Anbieter und Betreiber von öffentlichen Kommunikationsnetzen zur Speicherung der sogenannten Verkehrsdaten verpflichten. Ein konkreter Anlass ist für diese Erfassung der TK-Nutzer nicht erforderlich. Mit diesen Daten soll die eindeutige Rückverfolgung und Identifizierung der Quelle und des Adressaten einer Nachricht nach Datum, Uhrzeit, Dauer, Art der Nachrichtenübermittlung sowie die Bestimmung der Enteinrichtung und des Standorts mobiler Geräte, also beispielsweise Handys, ermöglicht werden. Als Speicherdauer ist der Zeitraum von sechs Monaten bis zu zwei Jahren vorgesehen.
Ja, zwei Jahre bis zu zwei Jahren in Deutschland sind jetzt gerade sechs Monate, vielleicht werden es aber noch zwölf Monate im Gespräch. Das heißt also, es sollen nicht die ganzen Inhalte, also die Gesprächsinhalte, was ihr telefoniert, was in den E-Mails drinsteht, mit gespeichert werden, sondern nur in Anführungszeichen, wer wann mit wem telefoniert. Das ist aber schlimm genug, weil wenn ihr euch überlegt, allein die Informationen, wann ihr mit euren Freunden telefoniert habt, mit wem, wer wann wie, unter welchen Umständen, wem ihr welche E-Mail geschrieben habt und auch welche Webseiten ihr aufgerufen habt oder mit wem ihr kommuniziert habt. Diese Sachen werden dann alle gespeichert und für mindestens sechs Monate in der Praxis sind es eher acht Monate, weil da kommt ja noch ein bisschen sozusagen noch ein Monat dazu, bis dann die Rechnung verschickt wird und so Geschichten. Das wird dann alles gespeichert und für Behörden in bestimmten Fällen abrufbar gemacht.
Richtlinie 2006-24-EG ist eigentlich ein astreines Passwort für die Festplatte, oder?
Naja, hierzu kann man vielleicht auch nur mal allgemein sagen, der Juristen nennen diese jetzt immer schon den europäischen Umweg. Wir hatten ja, was diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung betrifft, ein ganz eindeutiges Vortum unseres Parlamentes. Denn unser Bundestag hat darüber schon mal entschieden, nämlich genau, dass wir nicht diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung einführen. Naja, und wie in anderen Fällen auch, ist da einfach dieser Umweg über Europa genommen worden, sodass wir jetzt diese Richtlinie haben, die dann in nationale Gesetzgebung umgesetzt wird.
Wobei Deutschland sogar auch die Möglichkeit hätte sagen, nein, das machen wir nicht, denn würde es ein Vertragsverletzungsverfahren geben, möglicherweise. Wobei man muss auch sagen, diese Richtlinie, die von der EU kommt, ist auch nicht unumstritten. Das heißt, sie ist jetzt sogar auch vor dem Europäischen Gerichtshof, weil es da eigentlich einen Verfahrensfehler gab. Also es kann gut sein, dass diese Richtlinie für sich schon als nicht zulässig erklärt wird, als nicht gültig erklärt wird. Und dann hätten wir die Situation, dass Deutschland eine EU-Richtlinie in deutsches Recht umgesetzt hätte für eine Richtlinie, die gar nicht mehr da ist, die gar nicht mehr gültig ist. Das heißt, dann hätte Deutschland voraus einen Gehorsam geleistet und wir hätten eine Sache umgesetzt, die überhaupt gar nicht notwendig gewesen wäre und die zumindest aus unserer Sicht auch verfassungswidrig ist. Und da sind wir auch nicht ganz alleine, sagen eigentlich auch die meisten Juristen.
Also mit großem Applaus, mit großem Jubel der Preis an Frau Zypries im Bereich Kommunikation, Big Brother Award 2007. Die hat den nun gekriegt, die war ja nicht da. Wie kriegt denn die den? Schickt ihr der ein Paket? Das ist ja wie so eine Statue, die sieht so ein bisschen aus wie der Oscar, nur etwas eben abgewandelt. Schickt ihr der dann irgendwie ein Paket und dann kommt der Postbote und sagt, Ding Dong, Frau Zypries, ich hab ein Geschenk für Sie und ich stell's oben auf den Sims, wahrscheinlich nicht?
Nee, also wir laden die schon ein zur Preisverleihung zu kommen und da den Preis entgegenzunehmen. Und bei Firmen ist es üblich, bei Ministerien auch, dass wir halt vorher den Geschäftsführer, den Datenschutzbeauftragten der Firma, wenn es den gibt, und auch die Öffentlichkeitsabteilung, Presseabteilung davon, Presseverantwortlichen informieren. Dass hinterher auch keiner sagen kann, da ist es irgendwo im Faxklemmen geblieben oder so was, wir haben es nicht bekommen, wussten wir gar nichts von. Also wir versuchen, das der Firma auch schon klar zu machen. Wir meinen es so, es ist wirklich so gemeint und wir würden uns freuen und raten, in das Jahr zu kommen, diesen Preis entgegenzunehmen. Aber wie gesagt, bisher gab es nur eine Firma, die ihn abgeholt hat.
Naja, man muss vielleicht gerade bei der Bundesministerin auch mal sehen, das ist die Bundesjustizministerin, die ist auch nur Juristin selbstverständlich, dass sie also in so einer Weise die ja mittlerweile mehreren Urteile des Bundesverfassungsgerichts so ignoriert und sich nicht als oberste Juristin quasi hinstellt und sagt, also einfach diejenigen unter den Juristen, die dir sehr stark bekämpfen, die große Mehrheit der Juristen, einfach da unterstützt und sich dagegen stemmt, ist schon undenk.
Also manchmal hat man das Gefühl, sie wird irgendwie von Aliens ferngesteuert oder so. Das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen, dass jemand wirklich einfach so resistent ist dagegen. Nichtsdestotrotz ist es eine Sache, die nochmal auch im Bundestag, wenn ich gucken zu Konstanz, über im Bundestag entschieden wird, nämlich nächste Woche. Und deswegen gibt es auch anlässlich dieser Entscheidung, dieser Diskussion zu der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, auch nochmal eine große Demonstration. Zudem der Arbeitskreis Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Aufruf der CTC und etliche Gruppen und Verbände sind auch Unterstützer. Das ist am kommenden Dienstag.
Und das ist unmittelbar vor dem Reichstag.
Richtig, also es ist wirklich vor dem Reichstag. Und dann wird es ja nochmal eine Veranstaltung geben, mit Reden, Bühne, wichtigen Rednern und so was. Und ja, da können wir eigentlich auch nur als CTC zu Aufrufen dazu kommen. Und da auch nochmal den Abgeordneten klar zu machen, wir Bürger, wir finden das nicht gut und bitte beschließt das nicht.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist sicher ein ganz großes Thema und ein großer Aufreger in diesem Jahr für den Big Brother Award 2007. Ihr seid im Chaosradio natürlich eingeladen, mit zu diskutieren und eigene Vorschläge zu machen. Wer hat in diesem Jahr aus eurer Sicht einen Preis dafür verdient, mit persönlichen Daten, mit privaten Daten umzugehen, als wäre es Konfetti und Seifenblasen auf einem Kindergeburtstag und die in die Gegend zu streuenden Leuten in die Hand zu drücken, die damit eigentlich nichts zu tun haben sollten. Dann könnt ihr gerne mitmachen, eure Vorschläge hier machen unter der 0331 70 97 110. Preis in Sachen Kommunikation hatten wir gerade. Ging an Frau Zypries. Wir können noch mal ganz kurz in der Geschichte gucken. Die Preisträger aus den letzten Jahren. Selbstverständlich hat Autosci einen Preis bekommen für sein Lebenswerk von biometrischem Reisepass über großen Lauschangriff bis hinzu. Die Firma Philips hat einen bekommen, weil sie in ihren CD-Brennern eine Technik installiert hat, dass auf den Rohlingen gleich mal die Seriennummer vom Brenner mit integriert wird, damit man immer sehen kann, wer das Ding eigentlich gebrannt hat.
Nein, nicht nur das. Die Firma hatte ihren Kunden auch noch verschwiegen.
Das ist das gleiche auch bei Farbkopien übrigens. Also es scheint irgendwie die Masche zu sein, dass irgendwelche Geräte, mit denen man möglicherweise potenziell vielleicht auch mal dumme Sachen machen könnte, dass die gleich sich selber mal ihre ganzen Identifikationsdaten, sprich die Seriennummer des Gerätes mit drauf brennen, andere Informationen, sodass es dann hinterher leicht festzustellen ist, wer das gemacht hat. Das kann natürlich auch unerwünschte Nebeneffekte haben. Und deswegen waren uns diese Techniken auf jeden Fall in zwei Jahren gleich ein Preis wert.
Aber es sind nicht nur technische Sachen, sondern auch gesellschaftspolitische Sachen, wenn man es so sagt. Es gab mal eine Grundschule in Bad Oeynhausen, die hat die Daten ihrer Grundschüler an die lokale Volksbank weitergegeben, damit sie sich gleich mal um die jungen Konten kümmern. Oder der Innenminister von Hessen hat darauf bestanden, DNA-Spuren von unter 14-jährigen Straftätern aufzunehmen, um die gleich mal mit auszuwerten. Also auch sowas ist immer wieder würdig, einen Big Brother Award abzufassen. Und auch in diesem Jahr sind wieder Dinge dabei, die nicht unbedingt nur von der Bundesregierung kommen oder von einzelnen Abteilungen, sondern die auch aus der freien Wirtschaft kommen oder die aus Behörden und Ministerien kommen, wo man die Hände über dem Kopf zusammenschlägt und sagt, habt ihr eigentlich noch alle Nadeln an der Tanne? Darüber können wir gerne reden. 0331 77 97 110. Kommen wir zum nächsten Preisträger, oder? Wir müssen jetzt was ganz Schönes aussuchen.
Ja, was nehmen wir denn?
Ich bin eigentlich, ich bin Kommunikant, warte mal, Verbraucherschutz. Verbraucherschutzpreis ist echt der Hammer. Das ist echt toll.
Das gefällt mir wirklich.
Es ist jetzt so wie Weihnachten, wir wissen schon, was im Paket ist und ihr noch nicht. Aber es ist echt das echte Knaller. Haben wir einen Ton dazu?
Das sind die Hotels, ja genau. Und das ist dann die vier.
Also der Big Brother Award 2007 im Bereich Verbraucherschutz.
Der Big Brother Award 2007 in der Kategorie Arbeitswelt geht an die Novartis-Fahrradio.
Entschuldigung, mein Fehler?
Arbeitswelt?
Nee. Hochzentral der falsche.
Jetzt nochmal eine Anmoderation. Der Big Brother Award 2007 im Bereich Verbraucherschutz geht an...
Der Big Brother Award 2007 in der Kategorie Verbraucherschutz geht an die internationale Hotelketten Marriott, Hyatt, Intercontinental. Stellvertretend für viele weitere. Und zwar für das Sammeln und Zentralespeichern höchstpersönlicher Informationen über ihre Gäste ohne deren Wissen. Gespeichert werden unter anderem private und berufliche Kontaktadressen, Telefonnummern, Passnummer, Geburtsdatum, Nationalität, komplette Rechnungen, Pay-TV-Nutzung und Temponate. Das Hotelpersonal wird außerhalb des dazu angehalten, weitere Details über seine Gästeinsysteme zu notieren, wie zum Beispiel Familienkonstellationen, Ess- und Trinkgewohnheiten, Allergien, Hobbys, Sonderwünsche, Beschwerden und Vorlieben aller Art. Einmal erfasst, bleiben diese Informationen auch nach Abweise des Gastes gespeichert, und zwar auf unbestimmte Zeit. Dieses Vorgehen bewegt sich am Rande und zum Teil auch schon jenseits der Legalität.
Das kriegt einen Applaus. Das Hotelpersonal wird angehalten. Die persönlichen Vorlieben der Gäste im System zu notieren, die auch danach gespeichert werden. Dazu gehören Ess- und Trinkgewohnheiten, Pay-TV-Nutzung, Allergien, Kreditkartendaten und Sonderwünsche aller Art.
Bitte jeden Morgen den Spiegel im Bad reinigen.
Ist ja Hammer, oder? 0371 77 97 110. Was haltet ihr davon? Name, Axel.
Also ich finde, was hast du denn?
Jaja, genau, finde ich doch richtig toll. Und jedes Mal, wenn ich das nächste Mal komme, kriege ich selber zu essen vorzusetzen.
Ja, und kostenlose Allergiemittel gegen deine schlimme Stauballergie.
Richtig. Wie wäre es, wenn es das Zimmer sauber machen könnte?
Das Tolle dabei ist, dass die Hotels ja nicht mal eine Prozedur für sowas haben. Das wissen wir also von einem jemand, der das System kennt und das auch vorführen konnte schon mal. Es gibt also keine wirkliche Prozedur dafür. Für der Kunde wünscht diese Speicherung nicht, sondern wird es da einfach im Freitext vermerkt. Der Kunde wünscht das nicht und das war's dann halt. Aber die Sachen werden trotzdem gespeichert.
Das heißt selbst würde ich sagen, ich checke, was weiß ich, im HiHat ein, werde ich wahrscheinlich nie, aber ich checke da ein und sage, ich möchte hier in den Zimmer und ich möchte nicht, dass ich meine Daten speichere. Dann gucken mich wahrscheinlich die Rezeption mit großen Augen an und sagen, ich weiß voll nix.
Dann schreiben sie rein, wir notieren das hier, vielen Dank.
Sie wollten doch noch eine Cola mitnehmen, oder? Großartig.
Was ist dein Vorschlag oder dein Preisträger?
Mein Vorschlag wäre das Bundesgesundheitsministerium für die elektronische Krankenkarte. Oder Krankenkassenkarte.
Die haben noch keinen gekriegt, ne?
Haben die denn schon? Also ich denke, es wäre es wert, auch wenn es zur Zeit nur ein Versuchsstadium ist.
Was genau stört dich da dran?
Mehrere Sachen. Erstens, dass ich nicht verhindern kann, dass irgendjemand dann diese Krankenkarte ausliest, bei dem ich das nicht ändern kann, nach dem Motto Arbeitgeber. Sie werden nur eingestellt, geben sie doch mal ihre Krankenkarte oder bei der Einstellungsuntersuchung beim Arbeitgeber landet...
Du meinst so quasi freiwillig, ja?
Ja, quasi freiwillig oder bei der obligatorischen Einstellungsuntersuchung beim Arbeitgeber. Muss ich ja zum Arzt, also wie auch immer. Bei vielen ist es einfach zu verstehen, dass ich eine Einstellungsuntersuchung mache. Aber normalerweise erfährt der Arzt dort nur das, was er von mir erfahren soll. Wenn er dann allerdings meine Krankenkarte ausliest, was er als Mediziner ja sogar berechtigt tut, erfährt er auch diverse andere Sachen, die ich nicht unbedingt meinem Arbeitgeber sagen würde.
Du musst ihm die Karte natürlich nicht geben, oder? Dem Arzt muss ich sie geben.
Na, dem Arzt schon. Aber gemeint tust du ja eigentlich diese quasi Freiwilligkeit, dass man etwa dorthin gibt, diese Daten, weil man sich eben auf den Job bewirbt.
Moment, diese Krankenkassenkarte ist ja eine Krankenkassenkarte. Und wenn du zu einer betrieblichen Eingangsuntersuchung gehst, dann bezahlt es ja nicht die Krankenkasse, sondern der Arbeitgeber. Insofern darf der noch nicht mehr nach der Karte fragen.
Na ja, wie das praktisch aussieht, wissen wir aber natürlich.
Im Zweifelsfall haben wir ja gerade gelernt, dass der Arbeitgeber dann gegen einen geringen Obolus bei der Hired Married Interconti-Kette anrufen kann und sagen kann, welche kulinarischen Vorlieben hat er in der Zukunft?
Ja, und wie viel hat er denn getrunken?
Vor allen Dingen aber, welche Pay-TV-Angebote hat er denn da so extensiv benutzt?
Die besten Tennisspiele der letzten 200 Jahre.
Ganz sicher.
Zwei Stunden Abendunterhaltung.
Axel, das ist ein hervorragender Vorschlag. War der eigentlich, Frank, waren die mit in der Auswahl?
Ja, die sind immer schon seit Jahren mit dabei. Oder ist die Karte mit dabei? Wobei das Problem ist, müssen wir ganz klar sagen, es ist noch ein bisschen schwer tatsächlich auch, sag ich mal, was Greifbares zu bekommen, weil die gesamte Gesundheitskarte und das Drumherum ist noch so dermaßen in Bewegung und unausgereift.
Da sehe ich übrigens die nächste große Schwierigkeit da drin.
Nämlich?
Ich weiß schon, ich weiß aus früheren Zeiten, dass diverse Mediziner sich nicht so wahnsinnig gut mit der EDV stehen. Wobei das kein Vorwurf ist, sondern, mein Gott, sie haben eigentlich einen anderen Job. Und da besteht einfach die Gefahr, dass meiner Ansicht nach ganz aus Versehen irgendwann mal plötzlich eine Sammlung von Daten sonst wohin wandert, wo sie überhaupt nicht hingehören. Oder vielleicht andersrum, irgendwas auf meiner Karte wandert, was da nicht hingehört.
Das können wir auf jeden Fall voll unterschreiben. Die Arztpraxen sehen wir auch als größtes Sicherheitsproblem bei der ganzen Sache. Dass selbst wenn alles, die Chipkarten hoch sicher sind und die Rechenzentren der Krankenkassen und alles, aber in diesen Arztpraxen ist es wirklich Hanebüchen teilweise, was da an Technik steht.
Wir kennen da auch einige schwerwiegende Datenschutzrelevante Fälle aus diesen Arztpraxen, die im großen Umfang Daten abfließen. Da sehen wir auch eine große Gefahr, wobei ich persönlich denke auch nicht, dass sie das System dahinter so sicher kriegen. Und dass sie es auch von vornherein nicht unter Datenschutzaspekten bauen, obwohl diese Daten so sensibel sind.
Richtig. Aber dann muss man die eigentlich nur noch geeignet zusammenschließen. Das Harriett schließt sich dann mit dem deutschen Versicherungsnehmern zusammen. Und wenn ich dann das nächste Mal im Harriett einbuche, ich natürlich nicht, aber derjenige welche, kriegt er dann irgendwann einen Brief von der Versicherung, dass bei diesem extensiven Alkoholkonsum, also seine Versicherungsbeiträge in Zukunft, auch eher ansteigen werden.
Ja, und vielleicht kriegt man noch eine Werbebroschüre für Viagra wegen dem PayTV.
Ja, das ist auch eine Idee. Da sind wir doch eigentlich schon fast richtig. Ich hab irgendwie vorhin so mit einem halben Ohr gehört, ihr habt Ciba-Geigi irgendwie im Ziel oder Novartis, wie soll man das heißen?
Mmh, kommt noch.
Sehr schön, ja.
Den Pharma-Firmen traue ich also wirklich so weit, wie ich sie werben kann.
Die wollen nur dein bester Teil.
Schönes Stichwort wirklich.
Ich weiß, das primäre Interesse ist nicht mich gesund zu machen, weil dann verdienen sie nichts mehr an mir.
Schön formuliert. Aber Axel, das ist ein schönes Stichwort, wir können uns gleich mal der Firma Novartis, die haben ja auch einen Preis bekommen. Dir vielen Dank für den Vorschlag mit dem Bundesgesundheitsministerium. Schönen Abend, tschüss.
Wir notieren uns also mal die elektronische Gesundheitskarte.
Selbst Otto Schiedi hat damals dazu gesagt.
Das kann doch nicht richtig sein.
So, warte mal.
Übrigens, euer Spot mit der Online-Durchsuchung war ja wohl der Hammer. Den müssen wir noch mal hören.
Soll ich den noch mal raussuchen? Ich suche den raus. In der Zwischenzeit erzählst du was zu Novartis.
Novartis hat einen Preis bekommen, weil sie ihre Mitarbeiter beschnüffeln. Das können wir schon behaupten. Das ist auch wieder ein interessanter Fall, wo wir interne Informationen bekommen haben. Wir wollen auch noch mal darauf hinweisen, dass solche Sachen bei uns gut aufgehoben sind. Wir behandeln sowas natürlich absolut vertraulich und sind natürlich auch immer auf Tippgeber angewiesen. Das sind also gerade die spannendsten Sachen, auch bei der Firma Lidl, die vorletztes Jahr einen Preis bekommen hat. Sowas ist immer wichtig. Das sind Sachen, wo man normalerweise nicht reinschaut. Auch für den Umgang mit den Mitarbeitern. Da gab es etliche Geschichten. Das geht so weit, dass da auch Mitarbeiter nachspioniert wird, wo also geschaut wird, ob Mitarbeiter möglicherweise ein Verhältnis miteinander haben, weil die könnten sich ja dann verbünden und quasi Gruppierungen innerhalb einer Filiale bilden. Oder einen Betriebsrat gründen. Richtig, da wird also ein Leute hinterher gegangen. Es gab eine Geschichte, die soll in ein Tschechchen gelaufen sein, in einer Lille Filiale, wo weibliche Angestellte, Kassiererinnen ein Stirnband tragen sollten, wenn sie ihre Tage hatten, damit sie auch außerhalb der Pausenzeiten auf Toilette gehen durften.
Man muss da schon Menschen verachten, wenn man die sich da gelästet haben. Das war schon die schlimmsten Stories außerhalb von Deutschland, aber das macht es ja nicht besser.
Preis zurecht. So, wir kommen jetzt zur Firma Novartis.
Der Big Brother Award 2007 in der Kategorie Arbeitswelt geht an die Novartis Pharma GmbH, an Dr. Peter Maag, ihren Geschäftsführer, für die Bespitzelung ihrer Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer und die damit verbundene Verletzung grundlegender Persönlichkeitsrechte. Was erwartet man von einem Unternehmen, das sich selbst in unterschiedlichen Verpflichtungen faires Handeln auferlegt hat? Man erwartet jedenfalls nicht, dass es zum Standard gehört, Mitarbeitern im Außendienst in großem Spiel Detektive hinterherzuschicken, um minutiös deren Arzt- und Apothekenbesuche zu protokollieren. Man erwartet auch nicht, dass die Ergebnisse von Erhebungen am Arbeitsplatz, für die ausdrücklich Anonymität zugesichert wurde, dem einzelnen Mitarbeiter von der Personalabteilung bewährten Zug gegeben werden. Genauso wenig erwartet man, dass die mit der Durchführung beauftragte Agentur entsprechende Beschwerden mit dem Satz kommentiert, so naiv kann man doch nicht sein. Nämlich zu denken, dass der Auftraggeber die Ergebnisse nicht erhielt.
Da möchte ich nochmal den Innenminister zitieren.
Das kann doch nicht richtig sein.
Für die Bespitzelung von Mitarbeitern im Außendienst, um eine minutiöse Auflistung ihrer außerbetrieblichen Arzt- und Apothekenbesuche zu machen.
Bitte? Moment, es handelt sich um Pharma-Vertreter, also um Vertreter, die zu Ärzten und Arztinnen und Arztinnen und Arztinnen und.
Und da so eine Besonderfreichheit ist halt dieser Fragebogen, den diese Außendienstmitarbeiter da beantwortet haben, um eben ja schon in dem Beitrag zu hören, wo ausdrücklich gesagt wurde, das ist ja so eine anonyme Befragung und sie kriegen den halt nachher wieder und der wird ausgewertet. Also ihren eigenen und den auch mit so einer Bemerkung. Wie blöde seid ihr denn? Da muss man sich schon echt fragen, was da für ein Geist auch dahinter ist und was man über die Mitarbeiter, die ja diesen Konzern auch bilden. Man ist ja als eine Firma auch nur die Menge aller Mitarbeiter, wie man die da behandelt, das ist schon sehr menschenverachtend.
Gibt es denn eine Reaktion von Seiten der ausgezeichneten, also im Speziellen jetzt auch von Novartis?
Ja, also in der Regel ist es so, dass die Firmen sich dann irgendwann, dass sie denn wach werden und wenn sie sich in der Zeitung lesen, merken, ups, das war ja doch was wichtiges, da hat jemand Kenntnis von genommen. Und in der Regel kommt es dann bis, irgendwie ist ja alles gar nicht so, bis irgendwie Klage, Androhungen, weiß nicht was. Das ist eigentlich das Übliche, was passiert. Meistens, also bisher hat es immer auch im Sand verlaufen, weil wir natürlich schon vorher auch recherchieren und schauen, dass wir die Sachen auch belegbar haben. Und letztendlich bedeutet so eine Klage auch nochmal viel mehr Publicity, Negativ-Publicity für eine Firma. Und das überlegen sie sich dann auch dreimal. Was haben wir noch? Wir haben sogar noch was zu vergeben. Das haben wir jetzt sogar, ups.
Ach ja, wir haben heute nämlich eine Verlosung. Heute gibt es Geschenke im Chaosradio.
Wir machen erstmal elektronisch die Uhrzeit und dann Geschenke, oder? Und auch Wunsch einer einzelnen Dame noch mal diese schöne Geschichte.
Oh, die Tür klingelt klingelt.
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Hier ist der Verfassungsschutz.
Wer?
Der Verfassungsschutz.
Wir wollten eigentlich eine Online-Durchsuchung machen. Kommen aber irgendwie nicht ins Internet.
Und da kommen wir halt so.
Schöner wär's doch, wenn Freunde klingeln. Fritz würde gern mal bei euch klingeln. Aber natürlich nicht uneingeladen. Wenn ihr wollt, dass wir zu euch kommen, werdet Fritz Freunde. Dann besucht euch Fritz mit ganz viel neuer Musik. Wir wollen nämlich eure Meinung dazu. Zuerst neue Musik anhören, dann sagen, was ihr davon haltet. Und als kleines Dankeschön gibt's was auf die Ohren.
Ein speziell für mp3 geeigneter Kopfhörer CX-55 von Sennheiser? Für mich?
Tja, kleines Gastgeschenk. Werdet Fritz Freunde. Ladet uns jetzt ein. Alle Infos zum Fritz Freunde werden fritz.de Fritz Freunde, neue Musik spielen wir zuerst bei euch. Und das hört man.
23 Uhr. Oder um 11 nachdem. Fritz. Chaosradio 329, heute widmen wir uns dem Big Brother Awards 2007. Konstanze ist hier, Frank ist hier, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Ihr könnt gerne anrufen, mitdiskutieren, wer eurer Meinung nach einen Preis bekommen sollte. In diesem Jahr für schluderigen Umgang mit persönlichen Daten. Ruft uns an unter 0331 70 97 110. Wir hatten eben gerade die Geschichte von Novartis, das ist ein Pharmakonzern, der seinen Außendienstlern hinterher spioniert hat, um rauszukriegen, was die eigentlich wo treiben. Sehr schön auch die Geschichte mit großen Hotelketten, die unter anderem aufschreiben, was man dort isst, trinkt, welche Vorlieben man hat, welche Allergien und was man im PayTV gesehen hat. Und auch Frau Zypries hat einen bekommen für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, aber das war eigentlich abzusehen. Du hast in der Jury gesessen, Frank, aber eigentlich müssen wir eigentlich zum Preis kommen. Genau, wir haben ja heute auch noch eine Verlosung.
Ja, es gibt also nicht nur den Big Brother Award Preis, sondern wir haben auch noch einen anderen, das ist eigentlich keine Verlosung, sondern wir haben gedacht, wir geben das einfach an den nächsten Anrufer, die hier gute Vorschläge machen und aus Berlin sind. Der CCC beteiligt sich bundesweit an einem Filmfestival. Das heißt, wir haben nicht selbst gemacht, sondern wir präsentieren einen Film, der heißt im Englischen Scanner Darkly, im Deutschen Der Dunkle Schirm. Das ist ein Filmfestival, eine Reihe mit Dokumentationen und Spielfilmen von der Gesellschaft, von der Aktion Mensch. Und der CCC und der Arbeitskreis Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist da bundesweit Filmpartner. Das heißt, wir präsentieren es, wir sind dann auch meistens vor Ort in den Kinos, mit einem kleinen Info standen als Ansprechpartner. Und der Film ist insofern interessant, der ist sehr speziell von einer Machart.
Na ja, wir haben ihn einfach auch schon mal vorgeführt, nämlich auf dem Camp. Jetzt im Sommer, der CCC hat ja sein großes Camp und war doch eine sehr interessante Diskussion. Der Film regt einfach an.
Ja, also es ist ein Film, der handelt im Wesentlichen von Überwachung. Es ist ein Film, der im Prinzip als Zeichentrick gemacht hat, als normaler Film gedreht ist, dann aber nachgezeichnet wurde und jetzt wie ein Zeichentrick-Film daherkommt. Mit Keanu Reeves, auch wenn er nur noch schwer zu erkennen ist, aber er ist er erkennt. Also ich hab ihn erkannt. Ja, im Prinzip eine Kriminal-Story, kann man sagen, spielt in der Zukunft und handelt eigentlich von einer allgegenwärtigen Überwachung. Aber wenn man mal ein bisschen genauer hinguckt und diesen Film mal ein bisschen sacken lässt, dann merkt man eigentlich, dass da schon ziemlich viele Parallel sind. Zum einen zum Kampf gegen den Terror. Man kann möglicherweise auch eine Scientology-Zusammenhang herstellen, also einen Sekten-Zusammenhang. Also es sind ganz, ganz wahnsinnig viele Ebenen, der ist spannend. Und deswegen gibt es danach dann noch eine kleine Diskussionsrunde mit Leuten aus der Politik und auch von Bürgerrechtsvereinigung. Und da haben wir Tickets zu verlosen.
Wann und wo läuft der?
Der läuft in Berlin am Donnerstag, den 8. November um 20 Uhr im Filmtheater Friedrichshain.
Wer jetzt also einen coolen Vorschlag bringt für die Big Brother Awards und da noch einen Nominierten sagen kann, der kann mit einem Freund oder einer Freundin da hinkommen. Wir haben also dreimal zwei Karten.
Und wenn nicht, gehen wir alle allein hin.
Genau. Wir sind sowieso da.
Wir kommen jetzt gleich zur nächsten Nominierung. Vorher würde ich gerne noch Musik anbringen, die auch so ein bisschen ins Thema passt. Von einem jungen Herrn aus London, der heißt Pete Green. Nicht zu überwechseln mit dem People Mention, also Peter Green. Und Pete Green hat einen Song darüber gemacht, einen Song über die sozialen Netzwerke im Internet gemacht. Und der Song heißt I don't have my space because my space fucking sucks. Dieser junge Mann heißt Pete Green. Der Song ist zumindest im Moment erhältlich auf einem Sampler, der heißt They wanna make a shirt out of your dreams vom Cowboy Democracy Label. Und gehört habt ihr den hier auf Fritz im Chaosradio, Teil 129, es geht um die Big Brother Awards 2007. Wir haben wieder einen Vorschlag für eine Nominierung und zwar von Robert. Einen schönen guten Abend. Also ich hoffe, dass du Robert bist.
Naja, ich weiß ja nicht, wie viele Roberts es da draußen noch gibt. Also du bist Robert. Ich bin Robert, ja. Ich würde mal einen Preis vorschlagen für die Gesamtheit all dieser Menschen, die immer wieder sagen, sie sind auch anständig, sie haben ja nichts zu befürchten, warum soll man nicht überwachen? Genau, denn ich muss es euch ja wahrscheinlich nicht sagen, immer wenn man so ein bisschen versucht, auf die Gefahren hinzuweisen von dieser immer weiter zunehmenden Überwachung. Die häufigste Reaktion ist immer, ja wieso, ich hab ja nichts zu verbergen, bei mir können sie ja ruhig gucken.
Na, da hast du ja noch Glück. Also da wirst du wenigstens nicht angeschuldigt, irgendwie mit Terroristen zu sympathisieren oder nachts Fenster einzuschlagen, dann hast du ja noch nette Antwort gekriegt.
Na ja, dafür sorgt man dann schon selber noch, wenn man ein bisschen provozieren will.
Ah, du willst also zu sagen, den Gesamtpreis an den Teil der Bevölkerung verleihen, die einfach nichts zu verbergen haben und damit in ihrer Masse den vielleicht kleineren Anteil der Bevölkerung in den Hintern zu treten.
Ja, denn gerade erst durch diese Leute, die ja nun nicht wirklich wenige sind, wird all sowas ja erst möglich. Wenn jetzt, war es das Hyatt Hotel, das hier?
Also Hyatt, Marriott und Interconti.
Wenn die wüssten, sobald sowas ans Licht kommt, fährt nie wieder jemand ins Hyatt Hotel.
Richtig.
Auf der anderen Seite, würde das wahrscheinlich nicht so in dem Maße umgesetzt werden können.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn Ketten wie Ibis oder wie sie alle heißen.
Genau. Dann fangen wir uns noch für Ketten ein jetzt. Steigenberger.
Hyatt Hotel, Schnick Schnack Schnuck. Wenn die jetzt mitkriegen, dass man damit durchaus den einen oder anderen Cent verdienen kann. Weil es hat ja immer zwei Seiten.
Meins mit Privacy verdienen kann.
Na klar.
Wenn man ihre Daten nicht speichern soll, kostet es immer 5 Euro mehr?
Zum Bleistift.
Das wäre eine schwere Diskriminierung. Dann kriegen die Premium-Kunden, die auch noch alle Daten weggeben, die kriegen dann immer fett Rabatt und diese Datenschützer, die müssen draufzahlen.
Dann kommt man mit Schlafsack und Isomatten und sagt, kann ich bei Ihnen in der Tiefgarage pennen? Ich hatte Stellplatz 4C.
Aber das ist doch eigentlich bei den Rabattkarten genauso.
Die Payback waren ja, glaube ich, eine der ersten, die einen Big Brother Award gekriegt haben. Ich glaube, ganz zum Anfang, zum Debüt.
Naja, die Problematik, die Robert hier anspricht, ist natürlich wirklich eine, die hat eine tiefe Wahrheit. Die Verbraucher haben bei uns eine objektive Macht, einfach schlicht mit dem Geld, was sie ausgeben. Ja, und auch als Wähler. Als Wähler sowieso, aber jetzt im Sinne von kommerziellen Unternehmen. Und wenn die sich mal ihre Backen zusammenkneifen würden und sagen würden, dann gehe ich halt nicht mehr zu diesen Datenverbrechern, dann könnte sich wohl was ändern. Also dass halt Privacy auch ein Argument wird für Firmen, sich damit zu befassen, wie sie heute eine Nachhaltigkeitsagenda haben oder eine grüne Agenda, womit sie ihr Image aufbessern, könnten wir das im Bereich Privacy auch schaffen.
Wobei im Bereich Privacy, klar, hat man die Wahl zu sagen, ich gehe jetzt nicht in das eine Hotel oder das andere oder was auch immer, aber es gibt natürlich Bereiche, Robert, das kennst du sicher auch aus den Diskussionen, wo die Leute sagen, naja, aber ich habe doch keine Wahl. Also wenn wir über Vorratsdatenspeicherungen reden oder was auch immer, du kannst natürlich auch mit Bleistift und Brieftraube kommunizieren, aber die kann man auch abfangen.
Und das ist aber auch wieder Staat. Der Staat hat ja mit einem Gesetz eine andere Macht als so eine Firmenkette.
Und ich wollte jetzt also eigentlich zu einem weiteren Nominierten kommen, den wir nachher noch ansprechen werden, nämlich Deutsche Bahn. Die haben ja auch einen Preis bekommen.
Ja, aber findest du nicht den Vorschlag von Robert, sollten wir belohnen?
Du bist ja aus Berlin.
Ich bin doch hier nur die Knopfdrückhupe.
Sehr gut, dann lass doch gleich mal draußen.
Hast du schon was vor nächsten Donnerstag, Robert?
Nächsten Donnerstag? Nö, also wenn, dann könnte ich mir den sicherlich frei machen.
Es soll doch ganz schlechtes Wetter werden, wo man also irgendwie reingehen muss und kuscheln muss.
Dann schicken wir dich da mal ins Kino.
Bleib kurz dran und dann klären wir das mit irgendwie, wie du da auf die Liste kommst.
Jetzt haben wir mit ihr noch meine Daten. Ich hab ja nichts zu verbergen.
Das kriegen wir raus. Wir schicken dir dann ne Liste mit Dingen, die du letzte Woche gegessen und getrunken hast.
Okay, aufgezeichnet, bis gleich noch mal bitte.
0331 70 97 110 Euro Vorschläge für die größten Datensammel-Hynies im letzten Jahr. Big Brother Awards 2007 sind gerade verliehen worden. Frank vom CCC war unter anderem in der Jury, kann viele Sachen davon erzählen, hat auch schon ne Menge erzählt. Und wir hätten gerne auch eure Vorschläge für diesen Preis, der nächste am Telefon ist Pavel aus Berlin. Hallo Pavel.
Was ist dein Vorschlag, deine Idee?
Ja, mein Vorschlag wäre Windows.
Microsoft.
Ja, genau, Microsoft. Sendet bei jedem Update die Daten von den ganzen Brennern und richtig zu den Umlaufwerken, die man drin hat und so. Sendet das an die Windows Zentrale, also an Microsoft.
Mhm, also du meinst, weil sie damit ja auch personenbezogene Daten über die Hardware übermitteln.
Ja, also man muss sagen, man muss mit Microsoft in der Stelle ein bisschen den Schutz nehmen. Die werden nicht im Klartext, sondern es ist eine sogenannte Unique ID, das heißt also eine weltweit eindeutige Identifikationsnummer deines PCs wird erzeugt und die wird aus verschiedenen Systemkomponenten erzeugt.
Das habe ich jetzt nicht wirklich verstanden.
Da wird halt geguckt, da hast du eine Festplatte, Seriennummer 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 und ein Mainboard Seriennummer und die Grafikkarte und dann wird das alles in einen Topf geworfen und hinten rum kommt dann wieder eine Nummer raus, die aber jetzt nicht einen Rückschluss auf dieses einzelne Gerät zulässt, die aber insgesamt in der Summe sozusagen eindeutig ist aus diesen ganzen Geräte-IDs.
Aber wo Pawel schon recht hat, ist sie kriegt ein Update und gleichzeitig mit diesem Update guckt die Software, was ich da für eine Kiste zu stehen habe.
Ja, also Microsoft bemüht sich zwar sehr, aber an ein paar Stellen muss man mal sagen, das muss jetzt eigentlich nicht sein. Die Daten müssen nicht übermittelt werden. Und letztendlich ist es ja auch eine Sache, die auch der Gesamtheit von Windows nicht gut tut, weil die Leute oftmals auch diese Updates abschalten, weil sie Angst haben, es werden dann private Daten übertragen. Möglicherweise haben sie auch eine nicht lizenzierte Kopie. Aber das ist eigentlich auch die Ursache dafür, dass wir so viele Windows-Zombies da draußen haben, die dann irgendwie Spam-Schleudern sind oder für irgendwelche Angriffe genutzt werden. Das ist letztendlich auch eine Sache, die die Gesamtheit des Internets auch betrifft, wo Microsoft schon besser daran tun würde, wenn sie das in Zukunft vermeiden würden. Und letztendlich hat Microsoft ja auch schon ein Lifetime Award dafür bekommen. Das heißt also einen Preis für ihr Lebenswerk, weil sie es einfach nicht lassen konnten. Und insofern, auch wenn sie sich gebessert haben, aber es gibt immer noch genug Punkte, wo Microsoft auch Daten überträgt, wo es nicht sein müsste.
Und im Zweifelsfall reicht es ihnen einfach nachträglich mit diesem Lifetime Award noch mal kurz auf die Finger zu hauen und zu sagen, dründig.
Also sie haben da ja quasi schon den Preis für die Lebensleistung bekommen.
Ich glaube aber trotzdem, dass der Vorschlag von Pavel durchaus auch einreichend und auszeichnungswürdig ist.
Bist du denn aus Berlin und hast Lust, in den Film zu gehen?
Dann hast du was vor, nächsten Donnerstag. Hast du einen Vorschlag? Microsoft kann man schon mal...
Also der ist zwar jetzt schon ein bisschen her, die Lifetime-Award-Verleihung. Man muss schon sagen, also Frank hat natürlich recht, zumindest hat Microsoft erstmal einen Dialog angefangen und macht sich da ein bisschen mehr Gedanken als früher. Das kommt natürlich auch sicherlich ein bisschen von dem öffentlichen Druck, weil einfach viel darüber geschrieben wurde. Und weil vielleicht gerade in dem Bereich die Nutzer, die den merken, das doch unangenehm finden.
Aber es gibt natürlich, da wir über Datensammler heute reden, reden wir ja in vielen Chaosradio-Sendungen, aber heute natürlich im speziellen bei den Big Brother Awards 2007, es gibt ja immer zwei Seiten. Es gibt auf der einen Seite diese Firmen, um wie Hotels, Hyatt Marriott, Interconti die Daten sammeln, ohne dass man das selber möchte. Auf der anderen Seite stehen wir natürlich auch ein bisschen in unserer eigenen Verantwortung, mit diesen Daten vorsichtig umzugehen. Ich hatte, was war denn das vorhin? Ich bekam eine Mail. Zeitungsartikel hier, liess mal, ist ziemlich spannend. Das war also irgendwie, ich weiß es nicht, Süddeutsche Zeitung oder Handelsblatt, irgend sowas. Lies das mal und ich wollte den Artikel lesen, da steht es dann drin, ja den Artikel kriegen Sie nur, Sie können den kostenlos haben, aber wir hätten gerne von Ihnen Name, Vorname, Adresse, E-Mail, Ding ins Bum, so und so.
Keine Allergien?
Nee, aber wo ich dann denke, du willst den nur zum Artikel lesen? Das ist dann auch doof, also natürlich ist man dann selber auch in der Verantwortung zu sagen, interessiert mich das jetzt und ist es mir so viel wert, da so viele persönliche Daten wie meine Anschrifte, meine Adresse rauszugeben und im Zweifelsfall wohnt man dann immer im Gänseblümchenweg 28F. Das geht natürlich auch, aber zu dieser Datenschleuder gehören natürlich auch immer zwei Seiten, sowohl der Sammler als auch der, der sie verteilt.
In meinen der ZZC sagte ich schon seit Jahren, dass man sich mal vielleicht irgendwie bei freien Betriebssystemen umsehen soll. Man muss sich ja eh nicht in dieses Windows-Boot setzen.
Das ist aber eine andere Baustelle. Wir sind ja bei den Big Brother Awards 2007. Welchen, wir sollten mal wieder Nominierten aus dem Topf ziehen. Also wir hatten schon den Preis für Verbraucherschutz, der ging an die Hotels. Wir hatten den Preis für Arbeitswelt, der ging an die Novartis Pharma GmbH, weil die ihren Außenlinzlern nachspioniert. Und wir hatten selbstverständlich den Preis für Kommunikation, der an Frau Zypries geht für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Dann hören wir jetzt mal eine Sache, die in Hamburg gelaufen ist. Das war der Regionalpreis. Und da ist es eine Sache, man sagt, naja, Meldedaten und Modernisierung der Behörden und Bürokratieabbau. Und eigentlich ist es ja eine ganz praktische Sache. Und es ist ja auch zum Wohle der Kinder. Es geht darum, dass die Hamburger Schulbehörde die Daten der Schüler mit den Mädebehörden abgleichen. Aber hören wir rein.
Der Big Brother Award 2007 in der Kategorie Regional geht an die Behörde für Bildung und Sport der Freien und Hansestadt Hamburg, vertreten durch Alexandra Dinges Dirig, Senatorin für Bildung und Sport. Für die Einrichtung eines Schülerzentralregisters mit dem Nebenzweck, ausländische Familien ohne Aufenthaltserlaubnis aufzuspüren. 2006 wurde in Hamburg mit der Novellierung des Schulgesetzes und der Schuldatenschutzverordnung das Zentrale Schülerregister eingeführt. Alle Schulen des Stadtstaates müssen die Daten aller Schüler eingeben, worauf ein automatisierter Abgleich mit dem Melderegister erfolgt. Über das Schülerregister können nicht nur Kinder aufgespürt werden, die gemeldet sind, aber nicht zur Schule gehen. Nein, im Gegenteil, es können auch Schüler aufgespürt werden, die zwar zur Schule gehen, aber nicht gemeldet sind. Also Schüler, die sich ohne Aufenthaltsgenehmigung in Hamburg aufhalten.
Ja, das ist eine Sache, wo es viel Beifall, aber auch ein paar betroffene Gesichter gab, weil es eine Sache ist, die jetzt gar nicht mal so das typische Datenschutz technisch, Daten übertragen, Datenbankensache ist, sondern da geht es einfach wirklich um die menschliche Frage. Sind Kinder, die als illegal hier lebende und nicht korrekt gemeldet sind mit ihren Eltern, haben die trotzdem das Recht, zur Schule zu gehen? Will man denen es nicht gönnen, sondern die haben einfach auch ein Recht darauf auf Bildung? Und wie kann man das realisieren, dass sie zur Schule gehen können und trotzdem mit diesem komischen Status leben können? Und da ist auf jeden Fall dieser Abgleich mit dem Melderegister aus unserer Sicht eindeutig der falsche Weg. Damit wird ein falsches Signal gezeigt, weil die Eltern, die ihre Schüler dann zur Schule anmelden, ihre Kinder, die müssen auf jeden Fall sofort mit einer Abschiebung rechnen.
Ja, und da ist echt ein Missbrauch betrieben worden mit diesen Daten.
Wir haben glaube ich noch einen interessanten Vorschlag für eine weitere Nominierung, die also nicht bei den Preisträgern ist. Und zwar kommt die aus Wiesbaden von Patrick oder Patrick? Wie sag ich es richtig? Patrick, hallo Patrick, schönen guten Abend.
Ja, also es gibt ja in der Wikipedia gibt es ja einen Check User, dass bestimmten privilegierten Nutzern vorbehalten ist. Die dürfen halt nachgucken, ob bestimmte Nutzer sich halt angemeldet haben und dieselbe IP-Adresse haben. Ja und insofern halt Benutzer sperren oder sie nicht sperren. Und ich denke mal, das ist ja auch schon mal so, wenn jemand anonym bleiben will und verschiedene Benutzernamen hat, um halt anonym zu bleiben, ist es ja nicht im Sinne, dass Anonymen bleiben, wenn bestimmte Leute dann halt auf diese Daten Zugriffe haben.
Das ist definitiv nuttiert.
Ja, das ist ja eine interessante Nominierung, denn wir haben in diesem Punkt natürlich auch einige Kritikpunkte an der Wikipedia. Bist du denn schon selber mal betroffen gewesen?
Nein, also das hat nichts damit zu tun, ob ich betroffen bin. Also ich sage halt so, dass es halt ein Punkt ist, wo die Wikipedia halt Schwächen hat. Ich bin selber ja aktiver Wikipedianer gewesen, lange, lange Zeit.
Ach, waren wir das nicht alle mal?
Ja eben.
Ja und auch, auch, auch, ah, beiden Punkte habe ich auch noch.
Aber ich bin doch gar nicht fertig mit der Wikipedia, aber mach mal erst meinen zweiten.
Mein zweiter Punkt ist halt, wir haben uns heute gerade mittags unterhalten mit meinen Software-Kollegen. Wie es denn ist, wenn man jetzt halt komplett anonym ist und da gibt es ja diverse Anonymisierungsdienste, die es halt im Netz zu nutzen gibt, unter anderem JAP und... TOR Wie sie nicht alle heißen. TOR TOR, JAP und TOR, ja. Die beiden. Und dann ging es halt darum, ja, da hat, wo jemand halt Kinder missbraucht und hat halt diesen Anonymisierungsdienst verwendet. Und dann war halt die Frage, ah, ist es denn jetzt verwerflich, das zurückzuverfolgen zu wollen? Oder ist der Anonymisierungsdienst gut gewesen? Welches Recht ist höher, Kindesmissbrauch oder Anonymisierung?
Das ist natürlich immer eine schwierige Frage, dass man bei solchen Anonymisierungs-Server einfach natürlich Leute hat, die sich irgendwie kriminell betätigen, auf welche Weise auch immer, und diese Techniken verwenden, um irgendwelche kriminellen Aktivitäten zu verschleiern. Du meinst natürlich jetzt, ich verstehe jetzt zwar nicht ganz weit zusammen, was die Nominierung wäre, aber es ist natürlich eine schwierige Problematik.
Wobei es natürlich auch immer die Sache ist, dass die Leute, die sowas für schlechte Zwecke nutzen, sind wirklich in absolut minder Zahl. Das ist genau die gleiche Sache wie bei Ebay, da regen sich alle auf, Betrug und unehrlich und sowas. Aber es stimmt schon, bei der großen Zahl, die die an Transaktionen jeden Tag haben, ist es natürlich ein kleiner, kleiner Teil. Genauso ist es auch bei den Anonymisierungsdiensten. Und letztendlich würde man der großen Masse damit eine Möglichkeit geben, für ganz legale Zwecke und legitime Zwecke ihre Anonymität im Internet zu wahren. Nur weil ein, zwei Leute vielleicht mal das für irgendwas missbrauchen, muss man diesen Dienst trotzdem nicht abschalten oder für negativ befinden.
Ja, wie seid ihr denn in eurer Diskussion? Zu welchem Schluss seid ihr dann gekommen, als ihr darüber geredet habt?
Na ja, also wir waren da jetzt halt am Meinung. Also es gab den einen Teil, der gesagt hat, ja eigentlich würde würde ich sagen sofort kriminell ist kriminell. Und der Meinung schließ ich mich eigentlich auch an. Also wenn jemand halt irgendwas verbrechen verbrockt hat oder verbrochen hat, dann würde ich auch sagen, ja meine Güte, dann brauch ich das gar nicht zu anonymisieren, weil Verbrechen ist Verbrechen.
Na ja, aber dir ist schon klar, dass man technisch diesen Benutzer nicht mehr de-anonymisieren kann. Das heißt, zumindest bei der Benutzung von Tor ist die Anonymisierung tatsächlich vorhanden, sodass sie nicht wieder rückgängig gemacht werden kann.
Ja, die haben aber die Serverlocks doch, oder?
Nein, nein, nein. Es ist also technisch nicht möglich, rück zu verfolgen, wer die Anonymisierung benutzt hat, sonst wäre es ja kein Anonymisierer.
Also bei Tor ist es komplett, also ich weiß auch bei JAB, dass es dann noch die Lockdateien gibt auf den entsprechenden Servern, nur dann halt die Frage, wo stehen dann die Server und welches Recht haben die Server?
Ja, naja, da können wir noch mal eine eigene Sendung darüber machen, haben wir auch schon mal.
Sollten wir vielleicht noch mal mit auf die Liste schreiben.
Aber das ist halt auch, sag ich mal, wenn man halt Big Brother Awards vergibt, dann geht es ja auch darum, irgendetwas anonymisiert irgendwo hinzuschicken, also das ist ja der Gegenfluss dazu.
Wenn ich das jetzt mal zusammenfasse, dann würdest du vorschlagen, dass man für einen Big Brother Award auch mal wegen meiner, für mich ist es mal allgemeiner, irgendwie die Kriminellen, die die Anonymisierungsdienste benutzen nominiert, weil sie quasi die ehrlichen Leute, die einfach nur ihre Privatheit schützen wollen, damit irgendwie an...
Ich glaube, um mir einen Vorschlag zur Güte zu machen, ist natürlich ein sehr interessanter Aspekt, den Patrick in die Diskussion mit einbringt, aber ich glaube, hier verrennen wir uns ganz schnell.
Das führt wesentlich weiter als die Sendung.
Ich würde vorschlagen, dass wir das Thema Anonymisierer nochmal auf den Zettel der Themen schreiben, die demnächst irgendwann mal auf der Liste sind und deinen Wikipedia-Einwurf durchaus mit in die Vorschläge für den Big Brother Award 2007 schieben.
Bist du eigentlich aus Berlin?
Aber du kannst auch den Film trotzdem sehen, der läuft bestimmt auch bei dir in der Nähe. Ich glaube, Wiesbaden ist da auch.
Wenn du mal nach dem Übermorgen-Filmfestival klickst, dann ziehen die durch die Städte, also die sind überall mal. Ja, da wünschen wir dir viel Spaß.
Aber wir haben noch einen Vorschlag, der sich durchaus mit einem der Nominierten in diesem Jahr deckt. Und zwar kommt der von Julian.
Von wo rufst du an?
Ich ruf aus Berlin an.
Und mein Nominierter, persönlicher, wäre die Polizeieinheit Cavala auf dem G8-Gipfel. Und natürlich ganz besonders für ihren Verfassungsbruch und den Einsatz von Bundeswehr-Tornados über dem Camp Redelich.
Und vielleicht generell so die ganzen Aktionen, die um die Cavala gelaufen sind?
Ja, also nicht nur um die Cavala, sondern insgesamt um die G8.
Julian, greif dir jetzt mal das Wort. Julian, höre zu.
Die Generalbundesanwältin erhält den Big Brother Award für ihre Maßnahmen gegen Gegner des G8-Gipfels in Heiligendamm im Mai dieses Jahres. Zum einen hat Frau Harms beim Ermittlungsrichter des Bundesgerichtshofs BGH beantragt, auf der Suche nach Bekennerschreiben militanter G8-Gegner in Hamburg systematische Briefkontrollen durchzuführen. Zweitens hat Frau Harms angeordnet, von G8-Gipfelgegnern, die da militanzverdächtigt wurden, Körpergeruchsspuren aufzunehmen und zu konservieren. Beide Maßnahmen sind im Rahmen von Terrorismus-Ermittlungen und Razzien gegen Globalisierungskritiker durchgeführt worden, die sich damit bereits im Vorfeld des G8-Gipfels unter Terrorverdacht gestellt sahen. Diese Ermittlungen haben zwar bislang zu keinen Anklagen geführt, dafür aber zu umfangreichen Ausforschungen, Vorfeldausforschungen der Datenerfassungs- und Verarbeitung und Ausforschungen, die der Erstellung von Soziokrammen des G8-Protest und Widerstandspotenzials dienen.
Julian, für solche Treffsicherheit hast du zwei Karten für den Film mit Keanu Reeves gewonnen, nächsten Donnerstag, 20 Uhr, im Filmtheater am Friedrichshain. So du denn Lust hast, dahin zu gehen?
War es jetzt, hat es so ein bisschen das getroffen, was du uns vorschlagen wolltest, oder hast du da noch speziell, also die Polizeieinheiten selbst, da was konkret?
Also trifft schon dein, was du genau nominieren wolltest.
Dann danke für den Anruf, bleib kurz dran, damit du auch ins Kino reinkommst, wenn du da hingehen willst. Und wir machen nach den Nachrichten weiter mit euren Vorschlägen für den Big Brother Award 2007, wer denn einen Preis verdient hätte für die größte Schlampigkeit im Umgang mit privaten Daten 0331 77 97 110 oder aber fritz.de oder aber chaosradio.ccc.de.
Moment, Moment, Moment, warte mal, die Karten gibt's nicht zu kaufen, die gibt's nur zu gewinnen.
Opfer und Hinterbliebene der Madridter Bombenanschläge wollen gegen die heutigen Urteile in Berufung gehen. Sie kritisierten vor allem, dass die Richter niemanden als Organisator oder Anführer der Anklage schuldig sprachen. Außerdem sind nach Ansicht der Opferverbände einige Urteile zu milde ausgefallen. Der Spanische Gerichtshof hatte heute 21 Angeklagte verurteilt und sieben Angeklagte freigesprochen. Bei den Anschlägen auf Züge waren vor drei Jahren 191 Menschen getötet worden. Der Tropensturm Noel hat Kurs auf die Bahamas genommen. Zuvor war er über Kuba hinweggezogen. Nach Angaben der kubanischen Regierung wurden durch heftige Regenfälle etwa 1000 Wohnhäuser beschädigt. 2000 Menschen mussten in Sicherheit gebracht werden. Der Tropensturm hat in der Dominikanischen Republik und in Haiti bisher über 80 Menschen getötet und große Schäden angerichtet. In beiden Ländern werden noch viele Bewohner vermisst. Die Bundesregierung will deutsche Unternehmen und Industrien vor ausländischen Übernahmen schützen. Das Wirtschaftsministerium will deshalb ausländische Beteiligungen von mehr als 25 Prozent genehmigungspflichtig machen. Entsprechend soll das Außenwirtschaftsgesetz geändert werden. Die Bundesregierung will verhindern, dass sich milliardenschwere Fonds aus Russland, China oder den Golfstaaten in deutsche Firmen einkaufen um Wissen abzuziehen oder politischen Druck auszuüben. China will Informationen über Alter, Blutgruppe, Fotos und Fingerabdrücke von 40.000 Spitzensportlern in einer Online-Datenbank zusammentragen. Das berichtet der Sportinformationsdienst SID. Das chinesische Sportministerium will damit das weit verbreitete Problem der Altersfälschung bekämpfen. In China sollen viele Athleten falsche Angaben machen, um in besseren Altersklassen starten zu können. In der zweiten Runde des DFB-Pokals ist Titelverteidiger Nürnberg ausgeschieden. Nürnberg verlor beim Zweitligisten Jena mit 4 zu 5 nach Elfmeterschießen. Dem deutschen Meister Stuttgart gelang der Einzug ins Achtelfinale erst nach Verlängerung mit 3 zu 2 gegen Paderborn. Ebenfalls heute Abend gewonnen und damit im Achtelfinale sind Bayern München, Bremen, Hamburg, Dortmund, Essen und Bielefeld. In der Basketball-Bundesliga hat Alba Berlin das Heimspiel gegen Trier gewonnen. Berlin siegte mit 92 zu 81. Ebenfalls einen Sieg gab es für die Eisbären. Die Berliner gewannen in der deutschen Eishockey-Liga gegen Nürnberg mit 5 zu 2. Die aktuellen Temperaturen, Cottbus 4 Grad, Potsdam 8 Grad, Frankfurt ebenfalls 8, Neuropin, Wittenberge und Angermünde 9, Berlin auch 9 Grad. Denn Himmel ist wolkig heute Nacht oder zumindest locker bewölkt, aber es bleibt trocken zwischen 7 und 2 Grad in den frühen Morgenstunden. Von der Priegnitz bis zur Uckermark bestimmt eine dicke Wolkendecke auch morgen das Wetter. Örtlich kann es dort Sprühregen geben. Im Süden und in Berlin sieht der Himmel morgen besser aus. Am meisten Sonne gibt es in Richtung Neiße. 9 bis 13 Grad soll es morgen werden. Brandenburg A24 Richtung Hamburg. In Höhe der Ausfahrt Neuropin gibt es eine Ölspur auf der Fahrbahn. A24 Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Herzsprung und Neuropin steht ein defektes Fahrzeug auf dem Standstreifen. Stadtverkehr Berlin A100, Stadtring Richtung Wedding. Zwischen dem Dreieckfunkturm und dem Kaiserdamm ist der linke Fahrstreifen gesperrt. A111 statt einwärts. Im Tunnel Ortskern Tegel ist heute nach der rechten Fahrstreifen gesperrt.
Gute Fahrt.
Wenn das Fahrzeug kaputt ist, ist es entweder ein Fahr- aber meistens daneben ein Zeug.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5 dann Fritz in Eisenhütten statt.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Chaosradio 129 am 31. Oktober 2007 auf Fritz mit dem Chaos Computer Club mit Konstanze und Frank. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, schön guten Abend. Das eben war Musik aus den Staaten, ganz neu von einer Truppe namens The Black Kids. I'm not gonna teach your boyfriend how to dance with you. Daran sollte man sich mal ein Beispiel nehmen. Wir reden über die Big Brother Awards 2007, über Firmen ohne Überorganisationen, die mit Daten Schindluder treiben, wenn man es ganz freundlich formulieren darf. Und wir suchen eure Vorschläge dazu unter 0331 77 97 110. Der nächste ist Thorsten. Schönen guten Abend, Thorsten.
Hallo. Guten Abend.
Du rufst aus Berlin an?
Ja.
Okay. Dein Vorschlag?
Und zwar, ich würde nominieren im Bereich, weiß nicht, ob ihr so eine Kategorie habt, Terrorismusverhütung. Und zwar, da würde ich die NSA nominieren.
Die NSA, okay. Musst du mal den Zuhörern erklären, was die NSA ist, wenn du das mal kannst.
Das ist die Nationale Sicherheitsagentur, also quasi noch rasser als der FBI und CIE. Und dann kommt halt NSE, das steigert sich eben. Überwachungssatelliten etc. Datenverkehr.
In den USA.
Also allgemein verständlich würde ich höher zu sagen, das ist ein Geheimdienst. Und insbesondere auf die technische Überwachung, speziell zu dem Geheimdienst, der sogar eigentlich erst seit gar nicht so vielen Jahren offiziell als ein solcher so genannt wurde. Er war früher richtig geheim.
Na klar, also die Leute, die brauchen sich bloß mal die Filme angucken, Staatsfreund Nummer 1 mit Gene Hackman, dann wissen sie Bescheid, was ich meine. Dann müssen sie ja klar nochmal.
Und das ist alles Hollywood, das wollen wir mal kurz noch anmerken dazu.
Ist das denn eine Sache, die uns in Deutschland betrifft? Oder ist es ein Geheimdienst, der ist in Amerika, in den USA? Und da sollen sie doch machen, was sie wollen. Wir sind hier in Deutschland, betrifft uns nicht.
Und zwar, das hängt zusammen mit der Operation Albarich. Und zwar der Spiegel Nummer 37 vom 10.9.2007. Leitartikel war RF, Spiegelserie, 30 Jahre deutscher Herbst, Die Nacht von Stammheim. Und zwar auf Seite 20, im Deutschland-Teil, Operation Albarich. Und zwar da geht es darum, wie sie im Sauerland diese Anschläge verhindert hatten, diese zwei Konvertiten, die da zum Islam konvertiert sind, nur noch Hass auf Deutsche hatten und irgendwie sich da wohlgefühlt haben. Warum auch immer, wie auch immer, da weiß ich nicht. Also keine Ahnung, kann ich auch nicht nachvollziehen. Und zwar ich zitiere, und zwar von der ersten Seite, die Operation begann im vergangenen Oktober, nachdem der amerikanische Abwehrdienst NSE im Internet verdächtige E-Mails zwischen Deutschland und Pakistan abgegriffen hatte. Und das hat mich stutzig gemacht. Deswegen habe ich auch bei euch angerufen. Und vor allen Dingen, die NSE hat abgehört, hat deutsche Behörden weiter informiert. Der Heimat-Schutzminister von den Staaten hat eben Wolfgang Schäuble im schönen Offenburg Gengenbach besucht. Na klar, warum nicht? Und darauf sind die denn darauf gekommen. Und dadurch wurden Anstiege verhindert. Dadurch hätten Menschen sterben können. Und also in dem Fall, ich finde das auch kacke, dass die das halt überwachen. Aber in dem Fall wurden Menschen nehmen, also gerettet unter Umständen. Anstiege, Flughafen Frankfurt, irgendwelche US-Basen in Bahnen-Württemberg. Und das finde ich schon ganz gut.
Also in dem Fall hat der das gefragt.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Na klar.
Also der Punkt, an dem du dich gerade, also der das bei dir entzündet hat, war, dass die NSA-Mails von Deutschland nach Pakistan abgefangen haben.
Ja, darauf gekommen, weiter. Wo sitzen die und so weiter? Handyverbindungen, Fax-Net, Telefonnummern etc.
Warum wetze sie aber, wenn es doch ein sinnvoller Zweck ist?
Weil sie Gehäusen haben, Menschen zu retten.
Ja, also der Preis richtet sich ja an Datenverbrecher. Sprich, Leute, die Schindluder mit Daten treiben oder Missbrauch.
Ja, aber in dem Fall haben die eben mal positiv gedacht, die deutschen Behörden informiert und so unter Umständen Menschenleben in Deutschland gerettet.
Das ist ein Negativpreis.
Ja, vielleicht könnte man aber...
Ja, das war der Negativpreis, aber in dem Fall hat es ja positiv gewirkt, weil hätten die das nicht überwacht, wären die nicht dahinter gekommen, wer weiß was passiert wäre. Den Negativpreis eben, den Antipreis eben.
Okay, also vielleicht könnte man das so lösen, dass die den Big Brother Award in einer schöneren Geschenkverpackung bekommen als die anderen.
Genau, ja, machen wir es so.
Also ich meine, die Lustige an der Idee ist ja eigentlich nur, als ich mir vorstelle, dass man Kontakt aufnimmt mit der Presserstelle der NSA und sagt, guten Tag, hier ist der Bielefelder Verein Fürbot und der Chaos Computer Club, wir möchten Sie informieren, dass wir Ihnen den Preis verleihen, bitte schicken Sie doch einen Vertreter nach Bielefeld.
Weißt du, was wir dir sagen werden? Vielen Dank für die Information, das wissen wir seit zwei Wochen.
Ja, na klar, nochmal.
Danke für den Anruf, Thorsten. Nächster am Telefon ist Bernadette, guten Abend, Bernadette.
Der Berliner Besser noch, wie der German City TV.
Bernadette, du bist zum Radio.
Oh, Entschuldigung. Jetzt bin ich da. Ich wollte noch den EPUF vorschlagen, den elektronischen Reisensport, den wir jetzt haben. Ja, weil da sind ja ganz viele böse Sachen drin, die eigentlich überhaupt niemandem was angehen. Und ich meine, wenn man sich so einen Pass beantragt, dann fühlt man sich ja dann ab morgen übrigens wie ein Schwerverbrecher. Ja, genau. Also ich hab mir heute auch noch mal einen Pass geholt und hab mir das mal vorgestellt. Also das mit dem Bild ist ja schon ein bisschen scary, wenn man da so abfotografiert wird mit dieser Schablone und dann muss man das nochmal prüfen und dann ach nee, nochmal und dass das auch passt und...
Und ohne Lachen?
Ja, das sowieso. Sieht ja furchtbar aus. Und die Frage ist halt auch, was das bringt. Also das hab ich auch noch nicht so richtig verstanden.
Naja, also die Nominierung ist natürlich erstmal eine gute Idee. Bringen wird gar nichts. Und mittlerweile haben wir jetzt ja auch quasi offiziell, denn die Bundesregierung musste kürzlich in einer Antwort auf eine kleine Anfrage im Bundestag die Antwort herausrücken, dass innerhalb von fünf Jahren überhaupt nur sechs Passverletzungen bekannt geworden sind. Das heißt, wir haben in diesen ganzen Jahren eigentlich überhaupt gar kein Sicherheitsproblem mit unserem Pass. Und wir führen dieses Risiko-Experiment an der Bevölkerung trotzdem durch.
Für alle, die es noch mal nicht mitbekommen haben, ihr müsst, wenn ihr einen Reisepass beantragt, ab morgen müsst ihr auch eure Fingerabdrücke abgeben.
Ach, ihr müsst die Fingerabdrücke abgeben, ihr werdet erkennungsdienstlich behandelt.
Richtig. Bisher waren es nur ein Foto, was ihr abgeben müsst, was dann aber biometrisch vermessen wird. Das heißt, das wird dann digital in einem Chip im Pass gespeichert. In diesem Pappdeckel ist jetzt ein Chip drin, der wird per Funk ausgelesen. Da gibt es also keinen Steckverbinder mehr, keine Kontakte, sondern der ist dann da drin. Ja, der ist in der Pappdeckel, natürlich.
Also dann wird sich die Bundesdoktorei bestimmt beschweren.
Das ist keine Pappe, na gut, das ist Stoff, was auch immer. Es ist jedenfalls nicht in dem Plastikteil, auf dieser Plastikkarte, wie man annehmen würde, sondern das Ding, dieser Chip ist im Deckel mit einer Antenne. Natürlich, das Ding ist doch Pappe, oder?
Auf der jüngsten Informationsveranstaltung der Bundesdoktorei, wo sie wieder ordentlich die Werbetrommel gerührt haben für ihren supertollen biometrischen Pass. Da haben sie immer noch fünfmal betont, dass die Journalisten doch bitte Passdecke schreiben und nicht immer Pappdeckel.
Pappdeckel klingt aber auch. Naja, jedenfalls, da sind die Fingerabdrücke ab morgen drin. Und wenn ihr das jetzt verpeilt habt, versäumt habt, da hinzugehen und euch noch einen rechtzeitigen Reisepass ohne Fingerabdrücke zu holen, dann solltet ihr auf jeden Fall dann ordentlich auf die Kacke hauen und sagen irgendwie, das ist aber ganz schön scheiße, ich geb mir jetzt Zähne knirschend ab. Aber ihr habt dann immer noch die Möglichkeit zu verhindern, dass mit diesem Fingerabdruck durch diesen Funkchip noch böse Sachen hinterher gemacht werden, zum Beispiel wieder dort im Zentral gespeichert werden, indem ihr diesen Reisepass zum Beispiel mit einer Mikrowelle behandelt. Für drei Sekunden, das ist zwar verboten, das dürft ihr nicht.
Du hast auch jetzt hiermit dazu nicht aufgerufen, ne?
Nein, ich wollte nur mal erwähnen, dass ist natürlich so eine Peste, so was nicht aushalten, wenn man die aus Versehen in der Küche da kurz reintut. Aber wie gesagt, macht es nicht, auch wenn man hinterher nicht erkennen kann, wie die kaputt gegangen sind, die Chips. Der Reisepass ist für die Bundesregierung weiterhin ein gültiger Ausweis. Das hat die so gesagt. Das heißt also, es gibt bei uns an den Grenzen zumindest vielleicht mal ein bisschen komische Blicke, was jetzt mit diesem Pass los ist. Aber letztendlich sieht man es dem Pass ja auch nicht an, ob der Chip jetzt funktioniert oder nicht. Insofern könnte da einfach Schulterzucken sagen, uups, ist kaputt.
Also ist der E-Pass auf jeden Fall auch ein Kandidat fürs nächste Jahr für den Big Brother Award 2008?
Ich denke, dann ist er auf jeden Fall fällig, ja. Herzlichen Dank.
Wir können da noch empfehlen, wenn ihr keine Mikrowelle habt, könnt ihr auch gerne jetzt im Dezember zwischen Weihnachten und Silvester zum Chaos Communication Congress am Berliner Alexanderplatz kommen.
Ihr habt eine Mikrowelle da, weil ihr habt nämlich keine Küche.
Nee, wir haben so einen RFID-Suppe.
Es gibt noch eine elegantere Variante. Man kann nämlich eine Einweg-Kamera, ein Einweg-Fotoapparat mit Blitzlicht kann man umbauen in ein paar Minuten, dann löhtet man einfach ein Draht ran anstatt dem Blitz. Da gibt es auch Anleitungen im Netz. Das heißt, wer sozusagen nicht so küchenfixiert ist, sondern lieber ein bisschen bastelt, der hat dann da noch ein bisschen Spaß am Gerät.
Der ZZB bietet praktische Lebenshilfe und Ausweg aus der Datenfalle.
Bevor wir jetzt hier die kleine Hobbitek mit Jean Pütz, Franz-Stanze und Jakob machen, Bernadette, vielen Dank für den Anruf. Der Vorschlag ist auf jeden Fall mitzuberücksichtigen. Wir sollten nochmal einen Nominierten reinholen. Wir haben jetzt viele Vorschläge von euch gehabt am Telefon, aber jetzt nochmal zu den Nominierten aus dem Jahr 2007. Wir hatten, ich wiederhole es gerne nochmal, die Generalbundesanwältin Frau Harms für den Polizeieinsatz während des G8-Gipfels. Wir hatten die Novartis Pharma GmbH für die Überwachung ihrer Außendienstler. Du freust dich großartig über die Chinesen, oder?
Ihr habt doch bestimmt die Meldung in den Nachrichten mitbekommen, oder?
Die haben ja keinen Preis gekriegt. Die könnte man auch nochmal...
Aber echt mal, also die Chinesen.
Dann haben wir auch sehr schön im Bereich Verbraucherschutz Marriott Hyatt und Interconti, die Hotelkette, die von ihren Kunden und Übernachtern Daten auswertet, wie was essen und trinken die, welche Allergien haben die, was haben die im Bezahlfernsehen geguckt und welche Kreditkartennummern haben die angegeben. Auch eine schöne Sache. Und jetzt kommen wir zur Kategorie, Frank?
Zur Kategorie MMM. Jetzt muss ich gucken, wo sind wir eigentlich? Nein, wir sind jetzt auf jeden Fall bei der Steuer-AD. Und das ist der Preis, glaube ich, Politik. Wir haben dieses Mal nicht zwei Politikpreisträger gehabt, weil es ist eine rein politische Entscheidung. Und es geht darum, auch hören wir selbst.
Wir hören mal in die Laudation ein.
Der Big Brother Award 2007 in der Kategorie Politik geht an den Bundesminister der Finanzen, Herrn Per Steinbrück, für die Einführung einer Lebenslangsteueridentifikationsnummer, Steuer-ID, für alle Einwohnerinnen und Einwohner der Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Diese Steuer-ID gilt von der Geburt bis über den Tod hinaus. Begründet wird die Einführung der Steuer-ID mit dem Erfordernis, Zitatanfang, eine eindeutige Identifizierung des steuerpflichtigen Inbezäuerungsverfahrens, Zitat Ende, zu ermöglichen. Genau dies ist aber die Funktion eines verfassungswidrigen Personenkennzeichens, PKZ. Bereits 1969 erklärte das Bundesverfassungsgericht den Mikrozenzusurteil, Zitatanfang, mit der Menschenwürde wäre es nicht zu vereinbar, wenn der Staat das rechtflüssig in Anspruch nehmen könnte, den Menschen zwangsweise in seine ganze Persönlichkeit zu registrieren und zu katalogisieren, Zitat Ende.
Sehr schön. Herzlichen Glückwunsch Herr Steinbrück. Kriegt nicht jeder so einen Big Brother Award 2007?
Also nochmal ganz kurz, die Steuer ID, also Steueridentifikationsnummer, ist eine klassische Personenkennziffer. Also jede Person von der Geburt an bis 20 Jahre nach dem Tod wird dieser eindeutige Personenkennziffer haben. Wobei es ganz klar gesagt wurde, in mehreren Urteilen vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, sowas gibt es in Deutschland nicht. Wir sind keine Nummer, sondern wir sind Menschen. Wir haben einen Namen, wir haben ein Geburtsdatum, sind darüber identifizierbar, aber wir sind keine Nummer. Insofern gibt es sowas nicht. Es hat auch einen Hintergrund, muss man auch sehen, dass die automatisierte Erfassung von Personen im Dritten Reich zur Selektion, zur Effektivität von Deportationsmaßnahmen beigetragen hat. Und das muss man natürlich immer im Hinterkopf behalten, wenn man über Sachen wie lebenslange Datenbanken, Zuordnung, Kategorisierung und sowas spricht.
Ja, also diese Steueridentifikationsnummer ist natürlich auch ein großes Problem, praktischer Art. Also neben den Bedenken, die man aus historischen Gründen haben kann, kann man sich jetzt schon überlegen, dass natürlich etwa Versandhäuser oder andere kommerzielle Unternehmen sich die Hände reiben werden, weil mit dieser eineindeutigen Nummer kann man natürlich über viele Datenbanken hinweg Datensätze abgleichen oder aggregieren. Man kann damit eine Menge machen. Ganz sicher werden die kommerziellen Unternehmen diese Nummer nutzen. Und wo wir gerade beim IPAS waren, das ist ja quasi damals schon die zweite PKZ, also Personenkennzahl war ja auch der Fingerabdruck, als eine Nummer dargestellt, ein eindeutig und lebenslanges. Und ich denke, in beiden Fällen müssen wir wohl wieder über das Verfassungsgericht gehen und warten, bis das Gericht den Politikern mal wieder bescheinigt, dass sie die Verfassung gebrochen haben.
Zeit für einen weiteren Vorschlag von euch. 0331 70 97 110. Wer sollte ansonsten noch einen Preis bekommen für den Big Brother Award 2007? Ein Vorschlag kommt aus Magdeburg. Guten Abend, David. Du hast jetzt ein bisschen warten müssen, aber ich hoffe, dass mit dem E-Pass und so ist auch irgendwie, da hast du Verständnis für, dass das nach wie vor kommt.
Und zwar, ich würde zum Beispiel jemandem den Award geben, der GEZ.
Der GEZ?
Ja, alleine schon Vivis machen, um an Daten dran zu kommen und wie die es ausnutzen halt.
Okay, natürlich. Der Vorschlag war schon mal, schon mehrfach, ne?
Also der GEZ können wir leider keinen Preis mehr, wobei das stimmt ja nicht, wir haben dieses Jahr auch gesagt, also nur, dass schon jemand mal einen lebenslangen oder so einen Lifetime Award bekommen hat, heißt es nicht, dass sie nicht noch mal einen bekommen können. Microsoft ist ja heute nochmal vorgeschlagen worden. Es ist tatsächlich so, dass die GEZ als wirklich größte Datenkrake, offiziell mittlerweile auch schon fast gestempelte Datenkrake, da doch ziemlich viel komische Sachen macht. Wir sind ja hier, auch das Chaosradio muss man sagen, ist durch die Rundfunkgebühren finanziert. Und wir, wie wir hier sitzen, finden es auf jeden Fall eine wichtige Sache und stehen da auch absolut hinter. Nur das Problem ist tatsächlich, wie diese Gebühren eingetrieben werden. Da gibt es jetzt auch Diskussionen darüber, ob man irgendwelche alternativen Wege findet. Ich denke, das ist bitter nötig, weil das bisherige System ist einfach eine Datenkrake. Und wenn man sich überlegt, dass die jetzt auch von privaten Adresshändlern Daten kaufen dürfen, Adressen kaufen dürfen, vor denen ist also nichts mehr sicher.
Vom Einwohner-Meldeamt zum Beispiel.
Die kriegen sie ja ohnehin, ja.
Wie schnell man im Grunde genommen das kriegen kann, ja.
Also vom Einwohner-Meldeamt.
Also wie gesagt, das war schon öfter mal ein Thema in der Jury. Ich denke auch dieses Jahr ist das Thema GIZ wieder aktuell. Aber ich würde auch gerne nochmal betonen, dass man vielleicht unterscheiden soll zwischen der Art, wie die Gebühren eingetrieben werden, die sicherlich kritikwürdig ist und eben der Verwendung der Daten. Weil jetzt hier Fritz zum Beispiel als Radiosender hat einfach keinen Einfluss darauf, was die GIZ-Spacken machen.
Ohne GIZ hätten wir alle weißes Rauschen im Radio und das wären natürlich auch ein bisschen Dutz.
Aber wir nehmen mal deinen Vorschlag auf, der ist jetzt zwar nicht mehr so neu und die haben ja schon einen Lifetime Award, aber trotzdem danke für den Vorschlag. Toll Collect?
Die haben schon einen.
Nein, genau. Da waren wir auch ganz früh dran, bevor das Thema überhaupt gestartet ist, haben wir gesagt, okay, das funktioniert mit GSM Mobilfunk und irgendwie ist das alles so ein bisschen. Und dann haben wir gesagt, okay, Bom, die kriegen jetzt einen, egal wie sie sich rausreden. Mittlerweile sind wir schon fast wieder am Zweifeln, ob Tollcollect die richtigen waren, ob es sich lieber hätte gehen sollen an die Bundesregierung. Weil die haben ja fast noch ein größeres Interesse an den Daten als Tollcollect selbst. Da muss man sich jetzt fragen, wer der größere Datenverbrecher ist. Ist es das System oder ist es die Bundesregierung? Wer hat bestimmt, dass dieses System, so wie es ist, aufgebaut wurde? Oder war es die Bundesregierung, die gesagt hat, wir wollen so ein System haben, wo wir diese Brücken haben, wo wir überwachen können? Oder war es Tollcollect, die vorgeschlagen haben, wir haben ein tolles System mit Mautbrücken? Und auf jeden Fall muss man schon sagen, auch zu deren Rettung, die leiden jetzt ganz schön darunter, dass die täglich etliche Anfragen kriegen nach irgendwelchen Daten. War, lasst fragen, so und so, welches Auto da und da. Und die müssen mal sagen, nein, geht weg, ihr kriegt diese Daten nicht, das geht nicht. Wobei die Gesetzeslage auch sehr fragil ist derzeit. Das heißt also, es läuft schon eine ganze Weile, der Vorstoß von der CDU vor allem, dieses Autobahn-Maut-Gesetz auch wieder zu ändern, zurück zu ändern. Es ist also extra klargestellt worden, dass diese Daten nicht verarbeitet werden, dass die Verwürfe nicht genommen werden für die Strafverfolgung. Das soll jetzt wieder kippen. Insofern ergibt sich da vielleicht doch noch mal ein neuer Preis dafür. Zumindest für das Maut-Gesetz. Nicht für die Toy-Collect selbst, sondern für das Gesetz.
Freunde, dazu noch ganz viel sagen, wir werden da noch mal eine eigene Sendung zur Kennzeichenerkennung machen, weil hier nochmal spannend fällt.
Tschüss.
Wir haben jetzt noch nicht alle abgearbeitet. Lass uns mal schnell im Tiefflug noch die anderen machen, die auch Preise bekommen.
Ja, Wirtschaft, ja.
Ja, Deutsche Bahn ist wunderbar.
Die Bahn macht systematisch anonymes Reisen unmöglich. Die Deutsche Bahn will anscheinend alles wissen und stellt prallant voll und effektiv dafür die Weichen. Sie können zum Beispiel übers Internet reisen. Sie ahnen, was das bedeutet. Sie sind namentlich und mit voller Adresse und Ihrer Kontonummer dem Unternehmen Zukunft bekannt. Also nehmen wir dann vielleicht doch lieber die Umwegstrecke über den Fahrkartenautomaten. Kaum ein Automaten im Bargeld, da müssen Sie schon Ihre EC-Karte einstecken. Haben Sie eine Bahncard, um Fahrkarten zu einem halbwegs vernünftigen Preis zu erstehen? Damit man diesen Rabatt bekommt, verlangt der Automat, dass Sie die Bahncard ins Gerät stecken.
Dafür gibt es einen Big Brother Award im Bereich Wirtschaft. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, Deutsche Bahn. Dann gab es noch einen, das müssen wir jetzt mal ohne die Laudatio machen, weil Martin Peters ist auch sehr gleich dran mit seinem Nightflight. Es gab noch einen Finanzminister, hatten wir. Wir hatten einen für Frau Zypries, für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, den haben wir auch erwähnt. Wir haben außer Konkurrenz den Nichtpreisträger Wolfgang Schäuble. Wir haben für Behörden und Verwaltung Frau Monika Harms für die Anti-Terror-Maßnahmen beim G8-Gipfel. Wir hatten einen für die Novartis GmbH, für die Bespitzung ihrer Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer. Wir hatten den von der Bildungsbehörde in Hamburg für die Einrichtung von einem Schülerzentralregister, um gleich mal Familien ohne Aufenthaltserlaubnis aufzuspüren. Die Bahn hatten wir, die Hotelkette hatten wir auch.
Und, ähm, Technik! Kategorie Technik, da geht es halt darum, dass Versicherung, ein sogenanntes Pay-as-you-drive, Versicherungsmodell anbieten. Und, äh, das ist ein Modell, wonach die Fahrzeugversicherung, die Haftlichversicherung, danach berechnet wird, wie viel man fährt, aber auch wie man fährt. Das heißt, ob man jetzt, sag ich mal, schnell beschleunigt, rasant um die Kurve fährt und alles solche Sachen, kann man dann feststellen.
How's my driving?
Genau, vor allem geht es aber darum, auch, äh, fährt man viel Autobahn, viel Landstraße, da sind die Risiken unterschiedlich. Und, äh, die Versicherungen sagen, naja, also wir wollen auch vor allem, äh, Fahranfänger, über den Geldbeutel dazu bewegen, möglichst umsichtig zu fahren, Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzungen einzuhalten. Das Problem ist, man muss, das könnt ihr euch vorstellen, äh, sehr viel überwachen in diesem Fahrzeug. Das heißt, man kann einerseits die Bordelektronik anzapfen in neueren Fahrzeugen, man sieht ziemlich viel. Man kann Sachen sogar gucken, ob der Blinker gesetzt wurde vor dem Abbiegen, man könnte theoretisch auch einen Alkoholtester vor dem Start, äh, äh, notwendig machen, dass man also erstmal irgendwo reinblasen muss, so wird dann auch registriert. Und es gibt eine Firma, die Firma PTV, die hat dafür eine Techno- also, das ist nicht die einzige Firma, aber die ist nominiert worden und die haben wir uns angeschaut, die hat dafür eine Technik am Start. Und da haben wir gesagt, okay, wir geben denen mal den Preis dafür, dass das Thema auch in die Öffentlichkeit kommt, dass darüber öffentlich diskutiert wird. Will man so eine Versicherung haben oder ist es in Privatsphäre wichtiger? Und deswegen haben die einen Preis von uns bekommen.
Auch dafür gibt es einen Preis. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Äh, mehr zu den Big Brother Awards 2007, äh, im Netz, mehr zu dieser Sendung und zum Chaos Radio unter chaosradio.ccc.de oder aber unter fritz.de. Das war's nämlich heute mit Chaos Radio Teil 129 mit Konstanze mit Frank und mein Name ist Jakob. Äh, wir hören uns dann wieder in vier Wochen am letzten Freitag im November und hier geht's... Mittwoch. Mittwoch, natürlich. Ich bin auch schon ein bisschen ausgeknipst. Hier geht's weiter mit Martin Petersdorff und dem Nightflight und zum Schluss möchte ich gerne noch unseren Vizekanzler zu Awards kommen lassen und damit macht euch eine gute Nacht.
Wir werden als Koalition von manchen gemessen, von beiden Seiten oder von allen Seiten an dem, was in Wahlkämpfen gesagt worden ist. Das ist unfair.